you are what you consistently think
about whether you think you'll win or
lose you're right it's a challenge I
think a lot of us face we are stuck in
our head in our mind telling ourselves
why we can't do something why we're not
good enough we're born in the wrong
country we have the wrong skin color
we're the wrong gender we had the wrong
family we're the wrong education and we
just keep replaying these same stories
over and over and over and over and over
again and you don't win because you
believe that you can't win that's what
the great rewiring has to take place
inside all of us because that's why I
think that lack of belief is the world's
number one problem I'm on a mission to
solve the world's number one problem
people do not believe in themselves to
create amazing things I think everybody
has Michael Jordan level genius at
something that you are the greatest in
the world at something and it's probably
not what you went to school for and it's
probably not what your parents did for a
living it's something totally different
and a challenge in being able to go and
Chase down something that's totally
different is the belief that it's
possible need motivation watch a top 10
with believe Nation hey it's Evan Carl
Michael and I make these videos because
of my first business I struggled to stay
afloat I quit my business partner and
the thing that kept me going was
studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen to their wisdom
motivation gave me the Courage the
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's learn from me and my
team's take on my 10 rules of success
enjoy
because when you are around people who
are not living their life who are
complaining who are negative who may not
be toxic but who are stuck
people who are stuck
the easiest thing to do is to get stuck
yourself and to have the thought
patterns that keep you stuck this is why
I create all my channels
because I need it for me because I want
to be around people who challenge me who
when I see what they're doing it forces
me to think different to think bigger to
want to do more to want to be a better
Evan Carmichael whatever that means
right to just feel like I'm I want to
grow and do more because I'm around the
people who are doing that
where if you stay stuck with the people
that you're in right now you stay stuck
in the environment that you're
participating in right now then you will
likely stay there and not grow and not
improve and not learn and not get better
now
that doesn't mean that you stop caring
it doesn't mean that you stop giving
that doesn't mean that you stop
contributing it in fact it's the
opposite
you if you're watching this video you're
on a journey you're on a growth curve
and you want to go here right you want
to climb you want to get better you're
you're you want to go over there and
there may be people who are who are even
pulling you back actively saying not to
do that don't do that you can't do that
the goal isn't even necessarily to leave
these people behind
the goal could be to come back and help
them
but how can you help them and how can
you pour even more into them well by
learning more and improving yourself
more that every time that you learn
something and you get better at
something you can come back and pour it
into other people that when you're
taking your growth curve you're stepping
you're climbing you're improving you're
getting better every step that you take
you know if you now you move to step
number four you can help others other
people get the step number three you can
reach back and help them climb up
another step
so it doesn't mean that you stop being
optimistic and positive and helpful for
the people around you that's that's your
light that's your gift that's what you
are so amazing at
but it does mean that you need to
inject newness into your environment
because your environment is crafting
your thoughts and your thoughts are
keeping you stuck
you might have these moments where you
feel bold and brave and you can do
something else but those aren't
consistent and because the boldness in
thought is not consistent the boldness
and action is not consistent and so you
stay stuck doing the same thing knowing
that you're capable of more we're not
doing the thing and this is a game for
everybody this is this is for myself
this is for you this is for the people
who are ahead of you on their growth
curve you never want to stop there's
always a new level of of self-talk and
self-belief to get you to the next thing
that's possible
so it's why I do what I do because I
need it for me I need to be around
people who inspire me every day so that
I can continue to organize for kindness
right Martin Luther King had a great
quote about organizing for kindness that
people organize for negativity to
organize uh looting and the organized
violence and their organized Wars and
their organized negativity well who's
organizing for kindness right that's
what we need to do but you need to have
the inspired environment to create the
inspired thoughts to allow the inspired
action to come out so you can organize
for kindness too
so let's break down how do you actually
start doing it how do you actually start
to change that self-talk to be a more
positive one so that you can actually
follow through on the great ideas that
you have for yourself
number one
is to be around your Heroes who are your
Heroes who have done the thing that you
love doing either the actual work itself
like they're in your industry and they
have done the thing if you know my story
you know I looked up to Bill Gates he
had a software company I had a software
company I learned from him to build my
company I haven't met him but yet but uh
his strategy saved my company and then I
also learned from someone like Oprah
Winfrey or Kanye West or people who are
not in my industry but I just like for
some reason I'm gonna go and learn from
them so who are your Heroes either in
your industry or people that you just
look up to for some reason
and force yourself to spend more time
with them
be around them more put their pictures
up on the wall behind you my favorite
entrepreneur of all time is AP giannini
who started Bank of America put their
pictures on the wall behind you
subscribe to their YouTube channels if
they have it follow them on social media
read their books listen to their
podcasts like have them be in your
environment as much as possible because
they will transport you to another world
they will help you change that self-talk
in your head because the people who have
done the thing that you want to do your
Heroes the people you look up to likely
have done it with less than what you
have right now
the the resources that you have right
now the heart that you have right now
the the mental capacity that you have
right now the tools at your disposal you
know you have the internet you've got a
lot of tools at your disposal get a lot
of Technology at your disposal that your
Heroes didn't have as much access to if
any and they went off and won
so yes it might be difficult but if they
can do it you can do it too the question
is who you're going to listen to you
know the voice that says it's too hard
I'm never going to do it or the voice
that says well they can do it I can do
it too
so you have to be around you want to
change that self-talk you have to be
around your mentors Your Heroes because
they will pull you to a different place
step number two is to create a calendar
that has your habits in there your goals
that you've set for yourself needs to be
reflected in the habits because goals
don't accomplish themselves goals will
happen when you put time on your
calendar to go and make it happen I'm
making this video because it's in my
calendar this block of time right now to
go make videos right what do you need to
put in your calendar so that it's not
just a hope a dream a goal but it
actually becomes something that's in
reality and then to start to teach
yourself that you do the things that are
in your own calendar you want to start
to change yourself belief yourself talk
your that voice inside your head you
have to teach yourself that you follow
through on the things that you say
you're going to do have fewer goals have
fewer things that you write down in your
calendar
but when they're in there they get done
because here's what happens every time
you set a goal every time you put
something in your calendar and you don't
do it you're training yourself that the
next time you put something in your
calendar that's not going to get done
too you're losing credibility with
yourself not even somebody else saying
you can't do it it's you your own voice
saying you can't do it because you
haven't done the last thing that you
said you were going to do or the thing
before that
so the rate is start to rewire that is
to when you put something in your
calendar it's going to get done to even
lower the barrier lower the standard for
what has to get done for you to get the
check mark that you accomplished this
thing that when it gets put in your
calendar you are going to be the person
who actually follows through that starts
to shift identity
that starts to help you believe more in
yourself that the next thing that you
add in your calendar you're also going
to get done
so how do we start to change that
self-talk right that criticism or or
compassionate voice in our head how do
we how do we shift towards belief one be
around our mentors and our heroes the
people who Inspire us to do it two
create a calendar that reflects our
goals our actions have to map to our
Ambitions right has to be in your
calendar and teach yourself that you do
the things that are in your calendar and
step number three would be to collect
good people
I'm a huge fan of collecting good people
if you believe like I believe that your
environment is keeping you stuck and
keeping you where you are okay a shift
can be to be around your Heroes but you
never you may never meet them
good people when you're around the right
people
who fill you up as opposed to you
filling others up all the time it
changes everything you're a giver you're
caring you've got a big heart it's why
you're part of this community I love you
for that and keep going keep doing it
don't stop pointing to others
but who's pointing to you
when you walk away from a conversation
how often do you feel better about
yourself how often you have more energy
as opposed to well that was draining to
me you need to start to inject the
people who make you feel better who give
you more energy
and you may know some of them they may
not be the closest of friends to you yet
but whenever you meet somebody if it's
at an event or a conference or group or
in the comments section or on a Discord
and they just make you feel better
fight to try to find a way to spend more
time with them the way I'll often do it
is through businesses I end up setting
companies with them because I love them
so much it's a way to spend more time
with them
but it can be awkward at the beginning
like you don't know what you're gonna do
but you'll be the person to reach out to
say hey I'd love to have a coffee with
you next week or maybe we can schedule a
a monthly Mastermind with us and maybe a
couple other people like you reach out
to find a way to collect good people and
fight to spend more time with them
because when you're around actual humans
who are in front of you who make you
feel better about yourself and give you
the energy that you're pouring in other
people
it gives you more hope more momentum and
increases the chance of you actually
following through so get into the
practice of collecting good people
lack of belief is the single biggest
problem in the world you
have Michael Jordan level genie says
something you are the greatest in the
world at something
it's just your belief my belief too and
the ability to actually go and Chase it
down that will make the difference
between the life that you have right now
and the life that you know you're
capable of living let's solve that
together rule number two is outwork your
competition hard work is your ticket in
hard work doesn't guarantee your success
but it's your ticket in there's nobody
who you look up to who you respect who
you want to be like who did not work
incredibly hard to get to where they're
at now people say work smart work smart
work yes there's lots of people who work
hard and never get anywhere close to
their goals there's lots of people who
work incredibly hard who who stay
earning minimum wage their entire life
because they didn't work smart they were
only working hard but there's nobody who
just works smart and doesn't work hard
even if they're fooling you with their
pictures on Instagram it's that
combination of working hard plus working
smart I've covered
most of these people I've hung out with
a lot of these people I see the
incredible smarts that they have and the
activities that they choose but also
just the work ethic they have the show
up every day and stay consistent on
their goals
so in this video I'm gonna try to give
you some tips and steps on how to
actually do it like how do you stay
consistent how do you figure out how to
work hard but also work smart on
accomplishing your mission so
let's get it started first off you have
to actually love the thing right I mean
how many times have you started a
business because you thought it was
going to make you a lot of money
be honest I've done it too you started
business because you think it's going to
make you money
and then you quickly get bored of it you
quickly realize it's not making you
money and you don't want to do it
anymore
and you close it down and move on to the
next thing and so many people are just
opportunity hopping
jump to the next thing the next thing
and the next thing the next thing the
next thing without ever actually loving
any of the things and so you never you
never actually win you might make a
little bit of money here and there you
know you might be able to pay some of
your bills off it's great but you're not
living the life that you want
because you're just opportunity hopping
instead of actually finding the thing
that you love doing where the number one
rule for Success if you watch any of my
videos we've covered so many people take
my word for it or go do your own
research the number one number one guys
number one rule for success is that you
have to love what you're doing you have
to love the process the actual work that
you're doing
it doesn't feel like work because you
like it so much making videos doesn't
feel like work because I like it because
I like the process I like making it I I
like making this video more than
getting something like this right it's
great hey a million subscribers awesome
or the other channel is great
but I like I like the feeling of making
this video and knowing that you right
now are watching it
means something to me I like it that's
why I keep going otherwise it's crazy
you know
10 000 videos plus later why like how do
you keep going because I like you it
doesn't feel like work to me I talk
about it when I do interviews you know
how people ask me how do you not burnt
out already like so many people are
burning out on YouTube well it's not
just YouTube It's entrepreneurship
people burn out of Entrepreneurship not
just having a YouTube channel why do you
burn out of Entrepreneurship because you
stop actually liking there's too much of
the work that you're doing you don't
like it anymore
right there's too much of the work that
you're doing you might still love the
vision for where you're going if you
don't know the vision you got to get out
ASAP
but you might still love the vision but
you're just taking on too much activity
that you don't like doing anymore
so when I'm talking to somebody on their
podcast I like I like doing interviews
it makes me happy it brings me joy to
try to
hit somebody else's audience right they
try to spread believe to an even wider
net
and so if I'm talking to somebody say
well what is this work for you because
in talking to you this doesn't work for
me
this is fine
I'm Gonna Leave This interview with more
energy than I came in that's a sign that
you're doing the right thing so I like
this thank you you're you're giving me
you know I'm giving you content and
exposure for your channel but you're
giving me a gift because
this is fun you're giving me more energy
it doesn't feel like work
the second it starts to feel like work
you have to adjust and it might be it
might be a big adjustment maybe you
shouldn't be doing your business anymore
period because you just opportunity
hopping you don't actually love the
thing
or maybe you just need to make a minor
adjustment and realize okay this makes
sense as a strategy but it's just not
the right strategy for me I need to move
on and do something else even though it
works with some other people it's not me
I don't want to do it so that's what we
start transitioning to working smart
right so working hard is you showing up
every day working towards your goals but
that your purpose means something to you
and that the work you do you actually
enjoy and having fun in they're working
smart is then figuring out
there's so many different ways to win
inside your industry there's so many
different ways to win there's so many
people who have won
and there's not just one path this is
where we get locked up is feeling like I
have to do it this way but you don't
actually love doing it that way
and the second you start taking things
on because you think it's the smart
thing to do but you have no interest in
doing it you will never win you will
never win doing work that you hate it's
not going to happen you will never win
doing work that you hate you'll say that
you'll do whatever it takes you won't
you'll quit you'll give up on it because
you don't like it
chasing the goal alone is not enough you
have to actually enjoy the process of
getting to the goal that the process
becomes more important than the goal
gives you more satisfaction and
happiness and pleasure than hitting the
goal how many times have you hit a goal
and then been disappointed after right
he's like oh what's next sometimes
borderline depression right
Ted Turner's dad had a goal to hit a
million dollars he did it and then he
killed himself because he thought things
were going to change but he realized his
life was still the same
so having goals are really good and
important but more important than the
goal is the process of accomplishing the
goal you have to actually like the work
so how do you be smart well you have to
you have to do things that bring value
to people that you also enjoy
so in the course of my career on YouTube
at least said
got a bunch of great compliments
um the two that stand out in this
context are garyvee and Ed mylett where
garyvee said I'm the content DJ that
inspires people and said hey you watch
so many videos and then DJ it to inspire
people and Ed mylett said
that I'm the modern day Napoleon Hill
that Napoleon Hills the the greatest
person in person development history and
that I'm the modern day Napoleon Hill
now when they both sat down like
I'm still working on receiving
compliments so I was kind of Blown Away
by both of them and then I asked hey
well can I use that in my in my bio or
my profiles but what what I do is
I love I love modeling success you know
it's why I make all this content it's
why it's why I have all these people you
know behind me on the wall you know we
got we got Steve Jobs and AP giannini
and my parents and Howard Schultz and
Kanye West like I love modeling success
and and I want to share my own voice my
own thoughts my own opinions my own
learnings my own stories my own lessons
and somewhere in that mix is now Evan
Carmichael
where some people are if you look at
Gary or Ed or whoever else they're
they're just sharing their own thoughts
for the most part they might have guests
on the interviews they might
occasionally have a quote from somebody
else but it's it's their own views and
opinions
I never needed to be the guy you know I
like sharing other people's stuff I like
sharing what I learned from their story
and and I've reluctantly kind of stepped
forward to share my own I used to think
nobody would care about my story or
what I had to say or why would you care
about me when I'm showcasing Elon Musk
like who am I but people kept asking for
my story where I came from so I started
sharing it more and so in that mix
became Evan Carmichael that's how I'm
different than everybody else same thing
for you
you know what do you love doing that
then can also bring value to other
people and what combinations of things
can you bring together instead of
thinking I can do this or I can do this
in the mix is your next great
opportunity
when you can take two or three of your
interests and not do them as the or
right instead of thinking or you think
and
instead of or or you think and and but
not three different businesses this is
where people get tripped up it's not
three different businesses it's one
business that does all three of those
things combined in a way that nobody
else has done it before
because nobody can replicate that
the thing that you love doing or the
things that you love doing smoosh
together that don't make sense for
anybody else is and that is how you're
going to end up winning that's how
you're going to win
[Music]
James alticher calls it idea sex so you
have one idea and another idea and they
have sex and it out comes your your
great idea
I like it
that's how you start working smart
so working hard as you take it in
working hard if you're not willing to
work hard you're just not ever going to
win period how do you work hard well you
actually have to like the works it
doesn't feel like work that Jerry
Seinfeld calls it the torture you can
endure that is torture for other people
but for you he's like this is I like
this this is fun this doesn't feel like
torture you know if making the idea of
making 10 000 videos 12 000 videos
whatever
that would be torture for a lot of
people it's like okay that's cool I like
it let's go let's make another ten
thousand let's get going and then inside
of that is what do you love doing that
can bring value to other people in a way
that only you can do it by mixing some
of the things your passions your
interests together that have never been
mixed before together in that unique way
that's how you're gonna win instead of
saying that that's not practical instead
of saying that
um they're two different businesses
instead of saying nobody's gonna care no
no no that's how you're gonna win
you mix those things together
focus on how you can use that mix to
bring value to your customers
and now nobody can touch you for people
who say people message me and say hey
Evan this person is copying you this
person is also doing top 10 rules of
success this person is like I don't care
like I spend zero time thinking about
that because if you
are just trying to be Evan Carmichael
you're never going to be here from
Carmichael right the most you're going
to be is an Evan Carmichael Jr
instead of trying to be an Elvis
impersonator go make your own music
right so anybody who's just trying to
copy me I don't I don't care about it
it's the people who are creating new
Innovative things that I consider to be
the real competition
hard work is your ticket in
you have to love what you're doing that
allows you to keep going
then you have to figure out inside of
what you love how can you combine your
interests your passions your special
things that make you a special unique
snowflake
bring value to people
and when you figure that out that's the
unique angle of working hard plus
working smart that won't even feel like
you're
working hard or even working that smart
you're just doing you
and helping people
and that's how you win rule number three
is experiment the key to experimenting
is expecting to suck just expect to suck
expect it not to work out expect it to
be a total disaster expect to suck
which gives yourself the permission to
go and try we're holding ourselves back
from trying because you may not expect
to be great but expect to be pretty good
I think this is a problem for a lot of
entrepreneurs is you have an idea you
have a dream you don't think you're
going to be the next Jeff Bezos maybe
yes but maybe no you're gonna make your
own YouTube channel you're not going to
be great on camera but you expect to be
pretty good
you know you don't expect to be Bezos
but you expect to be pretty good in your
business and what ends up happening is
you start and you realize oh my gosh I'm
not only
not Bezos level I'm I'm terrible
I see it all the time people who are
starting their YouTube channels they
don't expect to be terrible on camera
they don't expect to be whoever you
think is a great on-camera personality
and then they record themselves and if
they thought they'd be like an 8 out of
ten they don't expect to be 10 they
think they'd be eight
and then they watch it back like oh my
gosh I'm a two
I'm a two out of ten and then they stop
and they never release the video they
never try the next thing because they're
convinced that they just suck that they
suck as a human
and that they'll never get the skills
well how do you get the skills by
practicing by doing just because you're
a two out of ten now doesn't mean you
can't become an eight or a nine or a ten
how do you get there how do you go from
a two to an eight or nine or ten at the
thing that you want to be great at by
practicing by learning by doing not just
by researching and studying and watching
other people you have to get into the
trenches and start to create and start
to make that's how you move
but people are too afraid to fail that
they don't even try
you're so afraid to fail that you don't
even try
and the way through it is expecting to
suck
I am right now learning about nfts
and now I know enough to be dangerous
about nfts but two months ago I didn't I
knew nothing I didn't know what it's
what it stood for non-fungible I don't
even know what a fungible token nothing
made sense I didn't understand what wag
me meant I didn't understand what lfg
meant I didn't understand what huddle
meant I didn't know the difference
between Bitcoin or ethereum I didn't
know what I meant a mask while it was
all of the stuff zero idea and the more
I I just looked at it from the outside
the more I got
stressed out confused overwhelmed I
don't understand any of this stuff I
feel like a total beginner and so I'm
not going to learn it
and I want to be the person who jumps on
things who learns things it doesn't
accept scary difficult or hard as good
enough reasons for me not to do it so I
dove in
and I asked all of those stupid
questions and I learned not just by
reading about it but by launching my own
nft projects and putting it out there
and starting to work with people I went
into the different discords and Twitter
I didn't even know what Discord was I
wasn't using Discord
nft land is Discord and Twitter I had to
install Discord and get active on it I
had to reignite my Twitter account like
you guys use Twitter I haven't used
Twitter for years but Twitter is where
the game is at so I'm picking up my
Twitter game again and I'm asking what
seems to be stupid questions I'm asking
all the beginner questions and I'm
launching my own nft project to learn to
understand and now I know enough to be
dangerous I'm not an expert at it but I
know enough to be dangerous
and that happened in a relatively short
amount of time because I was willing to
experiment and I was willing to expect a
sec at the beginning I'm gonna go in be
a total Noob right total total newbie
total beginner ask the questions and
then I'm going to learn through that
process and get better at it you can
surprise yourself with how much you can
learn
prize yourself with how much you can
learn at the beginning if you're just
willing to detach yourself that just
because you suck at a skill doesn't mean
that you suck as a human
this is where we get stuck it's like oh
I suck at that therefore I suck and I'm
never gonna get better so I'm going to
stop and go do something else that makes
me feel good
and sets you know I suck at this skill
and I feel good for trying and I'm going
to keep getting better at this so that I
can I can improve my skill from a two to
a two and a half to three to a five to
an eight to a ten right
so how do we start to do it how do we
start to give ourselves more permission
to experiment give ourselves permission
to fail give ourselves permission to
suck how do we do it step number one
trust your ideas
trusted the ideas that come to you are
good trust that idea that you're
thinking about right now is good just do
a quick gut check is are you trying to
rip people off are you trying to serve
and try to help are you trying to just
take their money put in your bank
account and go buy your boat or you're
trying to actually do some good right if
you're watching this channel hopefully
you're in the second category you're
trying to serve you're trying to help
you're trying to create something of
value so if that is your intention then
trust your ideas stop holding yourself
back stop saying that you can't do it
stop finding all the reasons in your
head that you cannot take action because
your Heroes have done more with less
than what you already have right now
whoever your heroes are whoever you look
up to Jeff Bezos whoever Oprah Winfrey
whoever they started with less than what
you have right now they could do it you
can do it too
you can
so if the idea is a good one it's it's
it's it feels right it's heart Centric
you want to serve you want to bring
value to people then trust that idea
trust it step number two immediate
action
immediate immediate immediate action the
problem is we get stuck in overthinking
over planning over preparing over
strategizing over asking other people
well what do you think I should do stop
that immediate action what's the first
thing that you can do
if you want to get an nfts go join
somebody's Discord go launch your own
single nft you're going to make tons of
mistakes perfect launch it you want to
launch a podcast great start your
podcast today you want to create a
YouTube channel awesome pull out your
phone record your video You're a
YouTuber now right you want to launch a
fashion business perfect create a logo
make a t-shirt like just start it
doesn't have to be anything great just
start the biggest thing for most people
that's missing is just momentum it's all
of these things stuck in your head and
not enough being created in the world
and to get all this organized and
structured and actually making sense you
have to actually put something out
so trust your ideas that they're good
that they're of value that they're they
will serve and then set number two is do
something about it immediate in the
moment action let's go stop overthinking
it and today something has to happen and
then step number three is just expect to
suck expect to suck expect it not to
work out expect not to make money on
this expect no comments no replies no
feedback expect to to just fail expect
it to be a total failure if you expect
that going in then you're not
you're not surprised when it doesn't
work out and you're not taking it
personally that you tried this thing and
nobody cares about it right now
you're lowering the burden for what has
to happen for you to feel good about
yourself
if you only feel good when you win then
you will never try
if you will only take
a yes and enter that competition enter
that race or do that thing if you know
that you're gonna win you will never try
you you will stay stuck doing the easy
stuff for the rest of your life and
never accomplish what you're capable of
never hit anywhere close to your
potential
so you have to expect it just to suck
and again by it's sucking by getting a
sucky result
it actually means that you're amazing
doesn't mean that you suck as a human
you only suck as a human is if you don't
try
to reward yourself for trying
search reward yourself for the effort
so to reward yourself for doing the
things that are outside your comfort
zone that are scary for you scary
difficult hard right you think of that
you're doing it and then you reward
yourself saying man I did that I can't
believe I did that was crazy
even though I didn't work out because
you know that if you kept trying and
kept learning and kept improving
that it of course is going to work out
you just have to show up with that level
of energy and enthusiasm and intent
every day
the difference between where you are
right now where you want to be is how
many experiments you're putting out
there
how many ideas that you've got that
you're trying
because you will not be rewarded for the
ideas that stay stuck in your head more
importantly you don't want to get to the
end of your life and look back and say I
had all these ideas but I was too afraid
of failing that I never tried any of
them
Wayne Dyer says don't let that song Die
within you
got to play the song while you're alive
you've got a great song in you
let's get it out to the world rule
number four is build momentum the only
thing you're missing is momentum this is
one of the most frustrating things with
entrepreneurs because you've got the
heart you've got the soul you've got the
desire to serve you know you're capable
of more you see these people doing great
things you say why why can't that be me
I've got everything I've got all the
tools why am I not having more success
when I see all these other people
winning because you don't have momentum
knowing alone is not enough watching
this video is not enough researching
going to conferences events it's not
enough it gives us this temporary high
it's so fun to think about where we
could be and what we could do when
living in dream mode of the things that
we want to create how That's so exciting
right but until you start actually doing
something and so you start going through
that little fear Zone to start actually
creating nothing happens and this is one
of the great missions of my life is
trying to get heart-centered
entrepreneurs with a cause you want to
serve and just getting you out of the
Starting Gate and then just helping you
stay consistent on the thing those two
things from idea to just doing something
and then finding a way to stay
consistent if you did that if you did
that's all you're missing if you did
that your life will be dramatically
different the people you're going to
serve the the amount of income you're
gonna make the life you can provide for
yourself and your family the the mass
massive just flow of goodness you're
going to create for the world will be
totally different you will be a totally
different person one year from today if
you did those simple things the only
thing you're missing is momentum the
only thing you're missing is momentum I
promise you
I look at
my YouTube channel and everything that
we've done here and man it took me so
long to get going it took me so long to
get out of my head it took me so long to
get comfortable making videos no matter
how much people told me just press
record and just do it I still was still
that voice inside my head is like well
I'm so awkward in front of the camera
and I don't know what I'm gonna say and
I I'm trying to memorize my script and
what camera should I find and all of the
things that we tell ourselves are
important that aren't
you know if you look at my growth on
YouTube the first five years was so slow
the first five years was so incredibly
slow because I started and stopped and
started and stopped and started and
stopped and convinced myself of why I
couldn't do it and my whole intent with
this is to try to shake you to say don't
waste five years like I did because in
the second five years that's when my
channel started to really blow up and
grow and that's when I started to see
the impact and see the growth and see
the see the the money coming in all of
it it started to take off because I just
started creating a lot more momentum I
stopped watching my videos and reminding
myself of how much I sucked and just
kept going
so how do you do it how do you start
building momentum how do you start
taking the thing that you know is inside
you that you know you're capable of more
that you don't want to be stuck in the
same spot one year from today it's like
I need to finally make something happen
right is that you are you ready for that
how do we actually start getting the
momentum in our lives I'm going to give
you three strategies okay
number one
your morning routine has to be on point
as I said on top of this video
successful people don't wake up and say
yes oh my gosh what a day I'm gonna take
over this is gonna be amazing I woke up
and I was tired I don't remember what
day it is and I got lines in my face and
I'm struggling out of bed right
everybody wakes up the same way
don't judge yourself and feel like you
suck because you woke up and you were
tired and didn't feel super motivated to
go off and crush your day right that's
everybody that's me that's Brandon
burchard That's Tony Robbins is Oprah
Winfrey everybody the difference is the
routine to set you up for success and
chances are if you watch this video you
already have a morning routine right
you're an achiever you have a morning
routine so I want to take this to the
next level for people with a morning
routine because your morning routine is
probably not working for you most of the
world doesn't have a morning routine
most of the world wakes up like an
accident most of the world wakes up
falls into their phone and starts
responding to other people's emergencies
right that's probably not you at least
not every day you might be 50 50 but you
probably have a morning routine
what's the value of a morning routine
the value of our morning routine
is to get you the feeling of bold
confidence and courage
that's why you have one routine it's
supposed to help you go and win the day
if you don't feel confident bold and
courage at the end of your morning
routine then you've done something wrong
either the morning routine itself is
broken and you need to add something in
or you just didn't do it with enough
intent
most Achievers here's what's happening I
want you to do a fair self-assessment
and audit of your morning routine most
Achievers what you're doing is you have
your list of things that you're supposed
to do in the morning and you probably
hit those maybe 70 to 80 of the time
but most of the time of those 70 80 you
just check in the box
you said you're gonna do this okay I'm
gonna work out I'm gonna watch this
video I'm going to read this book and
listen to this podcast so I'm going to
whatever but you're not intentional with
it having this video on I created the
espresso channel here to try to support
you to try to be there for your morning
routine to give you a shot of espresso
every day to start your day let's go but
if you're watching this video while
you're making your bed and brushing your
teeth and and looking over your email
and browsing through social media guess
what happens
you're not getting the feeling
you could check the box and say yep
watch the video but if you don't feel
courageous and bold
you didn't do it with enough intent you
didn't do it with enough Focus you were
distracted all the way through and so
this is what happens with Achievers in a
morning routine is you check the box for
all the things you said you were going
to do but you don't feel any better than
you did when you woke up
and if you don't feel any better than
you did when you woke up you're not
going to go off and win the day
so the most important part of a morning
routine whether it takes you five
minutes or three hours
is getting the feeling so do an honest
self-assessment
do you feel bold at the end of your
morning routine and if not would you
need to add in there so that you do
or do you need to go back and just do
your morning routine with actual
intention because if you'd started your
day with the thing that made you feel
bold powerful Unstoppable confident your
life will dramatically change when
you're from today I promise you so
number one is you have to fix your
morning routine
number two to get more momentums how do
we get more momentum in our lives number
two
is to go from idea to action
start to teach yourself that you come up
with great ideas normally what happens
when you get an idea what happens
normally when you get an idea
we get excited maybe you tell your
friends about it your family or you're
just researching and planning and
brainstorming you get excited about it
and then what happens is this little
voice inside your head tells you all the
reasons why you can't do it you can't do
it because of this because of that
because you don't have the connections
of the money the skills or the education
the family or whatever there's always
some reason and so the combat that you
try to do more research and more
planning and more more understanding to
try to have the perfect plan and this
was me guys I lost a 40 million deal
when I was in my 20s because I was
trying to be too perfect because I was
afraid and all I really need to do is
get more momentum so you have to teach
yourself to go from idea to action when
you get that idea
trust that the idea came to you for a
reason trusted the intention is good is
the intention good is the intention to
serve is the intention to help yes
perfect action something today has to
happen today use your best energy on
creating some kind of momentum in
Perfect action
versus trying to have the perfect plan
and then you wake up tomorrow and you've
already talked yourself down and you
can't do it so number one is you have to
fix your morning routine
number two is you have to go from idea
to action and then number three is to
change your environment
the more that you are around the people
who are doing the thing that you want to
do the more that that starts to seep
into YouTube
it's why I have so many channels because
there's always content hopefully out
there for you you might say yeah but I
don't know anybody Evan who's successful
I I can't hang out with Brandon burchard
or Oprah or whoever I don't know these
people great
I know Brandon but I know I don't know
Oprah
and I didn't know Brendan when I first
got started how did I learn from the
videos about having videos around me
every day having these people on the
wall behind me we even wearing this
hoodie when I feel like Batman putting
it on every morning makes a big
difference to start to change your
environment to be around the people who
are thinking the way that you want to
think the people around you right now
are influencing you to stay where you
are
might think about the people who you
hang out with now that old expression if
you are the average of the five closest
people to you yeah great so who are the
five closest people to you they are
influencing your thinking and they're
keeping you stuck where you are right
now and if you love where you are right
now great but if you know you want to do
more then you have to start to change
what starts to influence you
consistently not these one-off moments
of inspiration and boldness but
consistency that's the thing that's
missing you might have this one day
that's amazing oh my gosh I can do
anything and what happens you wake up
tomorrow and now that energy is gone
it's a start and stop and start and stop
and start and stop that is holding you
back
so be strategic with your environment to
think about how do I start to surround
myself with the people with the videos
with the books with the podcast with the
physical environment that make me feel
like I can do more that you can do more
fix those three things fix your morning
routine go for my day to action and fix
your environment do that because the
only thing you're missing is momentum
the only thing you have you have the
heart you have the care you have the
desire to serve you have great ideas
inside you
other people are winning with inferior
ideas with less of a desire to serve
than you do and they're winning and the
only difference is they got started and
they're going
the only thing you're missing is
momentum
I can't wait to see you actually start
to apply it to make massive change in
your life and your business also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is show up people
don't show up for one of three reasons
number one is you're afraid you're
afraid of rejection you're afraid of
failure you're afraid of it not working
out and so you just don't show up number
two is you're not consistent you show up
some days but you don't show up other
days because you don't have the routines
and habits in place to make you show up
consistently every single day and number
three is you don't want to you don't
want to show up because you don't
actually enjoy the thing that you're
about to do you would rather
procrastinate on it because you don't
love it and showing up is more painful
than just sitting around so my goal
today with this video is to help you
bust through these so that
the impact that you want to have so I
think the fear of showing up is actually
a good thing it means that you are doing
something different something outside
your comfort zone something that is that
is not normal that is new and that's
good you want to be pushing the envelope
if there was nothing that you are afraid
to show up to today tomorrow next week
then you're not growing you're not
learning you're not pushing against your
boundaries and comfort zones and so even
today I had to show up but and again it
should be every single day so today I
was procrastinating on sending out an
email to Grant as well as a couple other
people where I'm looking at doing more
collaborations more work on my YouTube
channel and more cross pollination
connection to other successful YouTubers
to help the whole entrepreneur YouTube
Community grow right I want to get the
message out there I want to be playing a
bigger game and so I emailed Grant and
emailed for the people with a new idea
that I had so when the idea was first
suggested to me about doing this and
reaching out I had a little bit of
nerves like okay it's gonna require an
ask I might get rejected it may not work
out and I had it scheduled for today
because today was my YouTube day and so
I look at the list today I'm like ah
maybe I should start with one person or
two people or just pick the easy people
and just the fact that I felt that just
the fact that that was one of the
reasons meant I had to go and do five I
had to do a bigger number I had to go
after the harder people I had to do the
people that I thought
may say yes may say no may make me look
bad if they say no and a lot of it is
just head games
the honest truth is Grant's probably not
gonna care Grant's probably gonna say
yes like 98 chance he says yes and he
passes on to somebody on his team we
start working together and we create the
collaboration uh one percent chance he
ignores it and one percent chance he
says no
but it's not the logical rational things
that hold us back it's the emotional
fearful things and so what I've trained
myself to do is anytime I feel that that
that oh my God it may not work out then
I have to do it I have to do it I have
just to show myself because the worst
thing you can do is get to the edge of
the cliff and say you're gonna jump and
then not jump It's better not to catch
that you're nervous it's better not to
even come up with the idea to just float
around in ignorance ignorance is bliss
than to catch it and then play small and
so as soon as you catch it I've trained
myself I want you to do the same thing
as soon as you catch it train yourself
to do it even if it doesn't work out
just training yourself that you don't
back down when you are afraid so I'm
going to give you a three-step process
you can follow to help you conquer your
fears to help you show up consistently
every day let's do it number one is tell
yourself that you do scary things one of
the biggest reasons why people don't
Advance their ideas forward is because
it's scary it's scary you're afraid
amazing that is now no longer an
acceptable reason you do scary things
you love scary things you Embrace scary
things you want to do scary things
this isn't just a mindset trick it's
actually actually true you
you what's the opposite of scary things
the opposite of scare if you walk
through life and you're never scared of
anything it's not that you're super
confident no it means that you're living
inside your comfort zone it means you're
only doing things that have zero fear
that you have absent certainty in
because you've done it before
you're bored you're living inside your
bubble and you need to break out because
that means you're photocopying your life
every single day if there's nothing in
your calendar that makes you scared you
hate your life and so pay attention to
the language pay attention to how you
talk to yourself pay attention to when
you feel afraid
and as long as it's not against your
code of ethics or doing something stupid
don't go jump out of an airplane without
a parachute because you're afraid
right most of the things you're afraid
of are not life-threatening
teach yourself that you do scary things
you love scary things and you're not
allowed to use as an excuse anymore for
not taking action number two is think
what makes you sore what is the thing
that gets you feeling bold alive
confident ready to take action wanting
to show up to life what is it I go
through five s's every morning as part
of my morning routine the versus sing
and then sun and then sore and then
sweat and then scare the most important
part is sore though it's a thing that I
do to make me come alive that makes me
want to soar and so for me what I do is
I think about an entrepreneur that I
helped yesterday and then I pull up my
phone and then I record a message and I
share that to my YouTube stories
Instagram stories Twitter LinkedIn I put
it everywhere
I need to feel like the work that I do
matters right now I'm just talking to a
camera I'm just talking into a camera
right now and and later it's gonna be
edited and it's gonna be thrown up on
YouTube and lots of people are going to
watch the video that's that's crazy it's
hard to imagine because I'm just sitting
here in my office talking into a camera
and so I need to remember that the work
I do has purpose that this matters to
some people right that people rely on my
videos every day as a part of their
routine and that helps make me soar so I
wake up just like everybody else I'm
tired I'm I don't know what time it is
sometimes even this morning I woke up I
didn't even know what day it was is it
the weekend is it I had no idea right
yeah wake up I'm not coming out of the
day saying yeah oh my gosh let's go
right that's not how anybody wakes up
nobody
that's not how Grant Cardone wakes up
Evan Carmichael Tony Robbins no but it's
not how we wake up the difference is the
habits that you set on a daily basis to
demand that success to demand that you
show up
and so what is the thing that helps make
you sore maybe it's remembering the
impact you want to have maybe it's
sharing a message to YouTube to
Instagram to LinkedIn maybe it's doing
an active service maybe it's meditation
maybe it's reading maybe it's watching
these videos what is it that makes you
feel like you want to soar and then
don't randomly hope that it happens
demand that is part of your morning
routine because if you woke up and did
the thing to make you sore to make you
feel bold confident Unstoppable and you
did that every day for the next year
your life will be dramatically different
you will not recognize the person who
you used to be
the challenge is you're not consistent
in soaring and so I need you to make
that part of your morning routine and
then number three is understand what is
your Michael Jordan Talent what could
you be the greatest in the world at you
could be the greatest the greatest of
all time at something you are but what
is that thing most people are living way
below their potential because they
settled you settled too early you
settled because you were pressured you
settled because you were afraid you
settled because you ran out of time or
at least you felt you did that's not an
acceptable answer anymore you could be
the greatest in the world at something
and if you're procrastinating on
something it's either because you're
afraid of the thing in which case you
need to go and do it because you do
scary you do afraid right back to tip
number one or two you just don't like it
you're procrastinate because you don't
like it and if you continue to do work
that you don't like
you're never going to be the best
because you're going up against people
who love it who love it
who love it
right if you're going up to play
basketball against Michael Jordan you
better love the game as much as he does
or you're gonna lose if it's just a
strategy for you you're gonna lose and
so look at the thing that's in front of
you look at the thing that you are not
showing up for it's for one of those
three reasons either you're afraid to do
it and therefore you must do it or two
you don't have consistent habits in
which case you need to put the thing
that makes you soar into your morning
routine or three you just don't actually
want to do it and stop forcing yourself
to do it go off and find the thing that
you have Michael Jordan level Talent at
rule number six is lose the scarcity
mindset you are staying small because
you're afraid you're afraid of the worst
case scenario coming true losing having
no money and being embarrassed but you
know you're capable of more you know the
way that you're going about doing things
right now is nothing compared to what
you're capable of unless you lose that
scarcity mindset you're always going to
stay small knowing that you are capable
of more today I'm going to show you how
so one of the easiest ways to get out of
your scarcity mindset is to go from idea
to action as soon as you get an idea you
do something about it and sometimes that
idea often that idea is going to be too
big too scary too crazy you can't do it
who are you to do this you don't have
the money resources time connections
energy right all of that all of the
excuses that come into your head I like
to teach myself that as soon as I get an
idea I go do something
it may not work but you have genius
ideas trust them go do something so this
is great this is a grant video because
when I did my tour in 2019 that's
January to April we hit 23 different
cities over 90 days and at the beginning
I was trying to find different sponsors
that would help out with travel
accommodations because it was me Nina my
film guy Danny and and all of our gear
was mostly Danny's gear
lighting and we had speakers and camera
gear and all of this stuff and we ended
up renting a suburban and driving across
America but before doing that I emailed
Grant and I said hey Grant
uh
can I use your plane for 90 days
for my tour
and to his credit
the email that he wrote back was what's
the upside not no not forget about it
not do you know how much it cost and
just jet fuel and and you know my pilot
and then I can't use my plane for three
months he said what's the upside I said
well listen I'm gonna let everybody in
my audience know about you and listen we
didn't get a deal we didn't make it
happen but it's that it's that idea of
going for my data action
right and I still do a lot with Grant
right making this video helping promote
all the stuff that he's up to we're
looking at doing something together when
I go to Miami next
and so that one exchange didn't ruin the
relationship and I'm happy to share it
publicly
maybe that's embarrassing for some
people right but the idea of trusting
your ideas you get an idea you go do
something it may be too big it may be it
may be scary you might have people say
no even if the most likely answer is no
right the most likely answer might be no
the most likely answer to me asking
grant that question is no right it's a
no but if I don't ask it's a no 100
don't take the no away from somebody
else
it might be 99.999 now but there's still
a little chance maybe this is Yes
somewhere in there trust your ideas do
something I did and so continue to do
and that's how you escape scarcity
mindset that's how you escape playing
small and actually go down and Chase the
life that you want to live so let's get
more specific I'm going to give you a
three-step process that I think will
help step number one is idea to action
so as soon as you get that idea you
don't judge it you don't think about it
you don't say why me you just go and you
do something find the smallest possible
way to just get started right so you
just trust that the idea came to you I
believe that ideas flow through you you
got that idea for a reason why are you
thinking about it don't worry about why
you're thinking about it just go do
something about it find the smallest
possible way to just go do something
about it you are a genius therefore you
come up with genius ideas not all of
them work out maybe the timing was wrong
maybe the execution was wrong but it's
still a great idea because you came up
with it therefore it is a great idea and
you have to go do something about it so
trust your ideas and go from idea action
tip number two is what I call the two
percent difference here's what happens
most of the time when people come up
with an idea you default into planning
mode planning strategy thinking
researching and then you wake up the
next day and you're back to square one
you're back to normal like the energy
that you got the boldness the courage
that you had is gone because you woke up
the next day
so you've wasted your best time your
best momentum that Peak in energy on
planning where what I want you to do is
use that for Action so the two percent
difference is instead of planning to get
to 100 which is what most of us will do
you come up with an idea and then plan
how it's going to happen 100 to finish
line so you know what the finish line is
going to be stop thinking you even know
where it's going to be instead of
worrying about 100 focus on the first
two percent
the first two percent I have this idea
what can I do right now right now that
will get me two percent of the way right
you wanna you wanna make a YouTube video
great pull out your phone start
recording that's two percent you want to
remind yourself to breathe this is one
thing we have on our on our door every
time I leave the door every time I leave
my condo there's a sign that says
breathe right because I want to remind
myself to breathe take take practice my
Wim Hof take 30 breaths in in and out as
I walk outside my condo every time
I put that there was a as a play bigger
trigger for myself but it's easy to
think well if I'm gonna put a sign on my
door then I need it to be a certain size
and I need to be at the perfect picture
and I need it to be framed and you make
it bigger and then you don't do anything
that's the biggest problem you just
don't have momentum you're not doing
enough
and so step number one the two percent
difference is I took out a sticky note
and I just wrote breathe and I stuck it
on my door and it's a reminder every day
to breathe that doesn't mean that you
can't go back and plan it doesn't mean
that you can't replace it with something
nicer bigger better yes of course
planning has its role but not as a first
step your first step is action if your
first step is planning you're losing
if your first step is planning that's
why you're a perfectionist that's why
you don't have momentum happening
against your ideas your first step
idea into the first two percent and in
Step number three is tie yourself forth
to the effort not the result this is
where again so many entrepreneurs will
fail because you tied your self-worth to
the outcome of you accomplishing that
thing if you woke up and you only did
things that you knew you were going to
win at you're going to play small for
life you're only doing things inside
your comfort zone because you know
you're gonna win at them right or a very
high degree chance you're gonna win if
that's all you ever take on you play
small for life
but if you're going outside your comfort
zone taking on new projects growing as a
human learning getting better checking
on new challenges that are bigger and
Beyond you most days you're actually
going to wake up and fail because you're
doing something new
but if you woke up every day and were
proud of the effort you were putting in
you're proud of yourself for the effort
you put in your max effort you're trying
to make the best video you can you're
trying to make the best product or
service you can you're proud of yourself
for the effort every single day
you're going to create amazing things
Way Beyond what you thought you're
capable of and way more than the person
who just sits inside their bubble doing
things that they know they're going to
win it
tie yourself forth to the effort not the
results rule number seven is live life
with intention you have to decide
whether you are going to live an
intentional or accidental life do you
want to live an intentional or
accidental life most of the world lives
in accidental life most of the world
they wake up what do you do when you
first wake up check your phone right you
set some alarm because you have to drive
to some job that you hate
you check your phone and immediately
there's all the crisis out there all the
expectations on you all of the fears and
judgments all of the tasks that other
people have set for you you wake up like
an accident and start living according
to other people's demands for your time
you've already lost complete control of
your day
what if though you swapped it and said I
want to live a more intentional life
what does it even look like was an
intentional life look like well I think
it starts with a value
if you were to think about what is your
most important core value would you come
up with right I've written two books on
it your one word built to serve back
there you can figure it out mine is
believe I want to spread more belief in
the world
what is your most important core value
that you want to organize your day
around
instead of responding to other people's
emergencies and losing complete control
of your day how about we organize with
intention for how we want to show up
today okay well that sounds great so how
do you do it well I'm going to give you
a couple tips that I use in my life that
I think can be valuable for you
number one your morning routine is so
critical you've heard it over and over
and over and over again from multiple
people Morning Routine Morning Routine
Morning Routine what's the difference
between a incredibly powerful morning
routine that allows you to be
Supernatural and do the things that are
beyond your comfort zone and and are not
by default in you yet
versus just a regular morning routine
the difference is the feeling this is
what most Achievers Miss okay most of
the world doesn't have a morning routine
with intent most of the world wakes up
falls into their day responds to the
people's emergencies hate their life
hate their day look back on the week
that just happened if you ever felt like
you've put so much work into this week
right you look at the end of the week I
worked so hard this week but I got
nothing done
you ever feel that way why because you
responded to other people's emergencies
instead of actually doing the thing with
intention that you should be doing
okay so the purpose
for Achievers I have a morning routine
is to get the feeling the goal is not
just to wake up and do your workout or
do your meditation or do your prayer or
or whatever the thing is that's on your
list right we're great as Achievers at
checking off the boxes right check check
check check I did it awesome pat
yourself on the back you feel good for
checking out the box but if you do not
feel
old powerful confident courageous belief
in yourself to start your day and have a
great day then your morning routine is
not working for you more important than
the task you get done is how you feel
about yourself and ready to start the
day
some people what they need to do is
actually tweak them on a routine and
some people what they need to do is this
is more likely the case you actually
have a good morning routine you're just
not doing it with the right focus and
intention because you say that you're
going to watch a video to get inspired
great perfect but while you're watching
a video You're brushing your teeth and
you're making your lunch and you're
preparing your coffee and you're doing a
million other things so you can check
the box to say yep watch the video but
you didn't get the feeling
and so it doesn't count
you need to feel bold courageous
powerful belief in self ready to start
the day and have an amazing one or you
have to go back and fix your own routine
or do it again starting your day to have
intention to do crazy new amazing big
things
it begins with a powerful morning
routine okay
number two
look at your calendar
and think about how do you want to show
up today the most important part of my
morning routine I'll wake up I put on
some music usually the first thing I
play in the morning is all these play
some really I don't know the oldies just
get me going in the morning any song
that kind of gets you moving gets you
flowing gets you out of your state
because we all wake up kind of tired
lines on your face Etc right but then
what song can you put on because it's
the fastest way to change your state
and then I look at my calendar
I look at my calendar and ask myself how
do I want to show up for today
instead of having a a bucket list I
think your bucket list is your excuse
list things that one day you're gonna
get done forget that I'm getting stuff
done today you're getting stuff done
today your bucket list should be in your
calendar you're working towards actually
achieving things and so look at your
calendar for today look at your calendar
for the next week how do you want to
show up
so this morning I wake up and put on my
oldies and I'm looking at my calendar
and this is a Tuesday for today and I'm
filming YouTube videos on Tuesday
Tuesday is a day that I film my content
so how do I want to show up I want to
show up
present I want to show up and make some
of the best videos I've ever made I may
not achieve that objective but it's my
it's my goal it's my intention to show
up it's less important like did you get
the result today and more like are you
proud of the effort that you showed up
today I don't want to focus on team I
don't want to focus on emergencies in my
email I don't want to focus on social
media I don't want to delay and
procrastinate I want to get content out
for you guys believe Nation let's go I
want to show up even though I'm just
standing on my trampoline alone by
myself in my office I want this message
to reach millions of people
that's that's the intention that's when
I wake up I got my oldies playing and
then I'm looking at my calendar and say
this is how I want to show up most days
I don't remember what day it is when I
wake up I I had no idea that today was a
Tuesday when I woke up
put on my oldies I look at the intention
ready to go that does not have to take a
long time this doesn't have to be a two
hour morning routine
you're you could be great at it
you're just not going through the actual
exercise to ask yourself how do I want
to show up today
so look at your calendars it's a good
exercise think of what's coming up in
your calendar today what's coming up for
the rest of the day before you go to
sleep how do you want to show up
how do you want to show up in your
business or at your work how do you want
to show up for the people that you work
with how do you want to show up for your
family how do you want to show up
because when you set that morning
routine right step one create a powerful
morning routine that makes you feel bold
confident powerful a live belief in self
and two as a part of that having the
intention for how you want to show up
imagine if every day for the next year
you did just those two things
powerful morning routine that makes you
feel bold powerful courageous right and
two you send an intention every morning
of how you want to live today
whether you achieve it perfectly or not
but you did that every morning imagine
how much different your life is one year
from today
just by doing those two things
it's transformative
and then step number three is
in between
the activities during the day
remember your intention I have a
background on my cell phone it says
remember your intention so anytime I
look at my cell phone it's remember my
intention remember your intention
remember your intent what was my
intention this morning belief I got it I
want to spend more I want to make
amazing YouTube content amazing videos
for you guys believe Nation remember the
intention because no matter what
happened in the morning you might forget
it come noon come two o'clock come four
o'clock come six o'clock
you need the reminder
of your intention so have it on my cell
phone background the other thing that I
do is I will book things in 25 or 55
minute increments
so if I'm filming blocks of content if
I'm doing meetings with people if I'm
doing training events or seminars
there's always a five minute break
from when I stop one activity to when I
start the next activity
and one reason for that is just to to
make sure that there's any technical
issues or one thing runs late or Etc I
have a little bit of a buffer but the
more important issue is that it allows
me that little window to reset the
intention for the next thing
so especially if you're switching tasks
you're coming home from work and you're
going you're going home and you're gonna
you're gonna see your spouse you're
gonna see your kids or you're switching
from one meeting to a next you're
switching from a meeting to making a
video or switching from video to write
your book you're switching between tasks
give yourself a little five minute
window to just remember the intention
again
it totally changes how you show up as a
human
if you are going from work to home even
if that's I'm I'm I my studio here is in
my home right even if I'm going from
here to outside the door
if I give myself a five minute break
in between activities from stopping
filming to then going to hanging out
with my wife
and I ask myself remember your intention
what was your intention for today
okay belief how do I bring that to Nina
how do I bring that to my relationship
even though I've just made all these
videos and my head's going a mile a
minute and I'm so excited for all the
content that we're producing and making
and launching amazing
how do I now show up for my relationship
is that five minutes it doesn't even
have to take five minutes but just
asking the question
resets the priorities
takes you off of living on autopilot and
living in intention
it changes how I show up to when I'm
gonna go out and hang out with Nina
so do those things your life will
dramatically change powerful morning
routine
set your intention every morning
and then have little breaks to remind
yourself of what that intention was
throughout the day
whether it's your cell phone background
whether it's five minute breaks in
between switching tasks
if you can decide
that you want to stop living in
accidental life
stop living a reactionary life based off
of other people's priorities for your
time controlling your agenda
put up a little bit of defenses and
walls to say no this is my time this is
my life
I'm gonna start living it with intention
you do that
Everything Changes I promise you rule
number eight is push yourself everything
in your life changes when you learn to
tie your self-worth to your effort
instead of the results
most people tie their self-worth to the
results to winning you only feel good
about yourself when you win if that's
how you think then you're screwed
because that person only takes on
projects that you know you have a pretty
high chance of winning at and therefore
you play small for Life the key is to
tie your self-worth to the effort to
trying and if you do that well you'll
win Beyond Your Wildest imaginations so
let's use me as an example look at this
video right here this video
two minutes before getting on to making
this video
I'm nervous
I'm scared
I don't want to do it I'm trying to find
a reason why I don't have to do this
video
now why I've done six thousand of these
videos do I not love it anymore nope
that's not it I love doing it
so why am I afraid
who cares I've done six thousand
the answer is because I don't want to
make it the same way that I've done the
past six thousand
I want to push harder I want to push and
do something new if I was just doing
what I've already done then it'd be easy
right if you're doing the same thing
over and over and over again it becomes
easy but then
you get bored
you start to hate your life
you start realizing that everything is
just a photocopy over and over and over
and over and over again
and so how do I push through
I put this pressure on myself to say
this video right now has to be the best
video that I've ever made that's my
intention going in to every time I'm
filming most days I don't accomplish it
when you're trying something new and
scary and bigger and Bolder most the
time you won't get it you fail a lot
but I tie myself worth my respect to the
effort I'm trying and every now and then
you'll make a bit of a breakthrough you
get a bit of a win
and then those accumulate and then you
get another one and another win and
another win and so the answer isn't have
a big goal and then find a reason why
you can't do it the answer isn't dream
big and then convince yourself of some
logical excuse for why you're not going
to take action the answer is to push
through
the answer is you're scared and you're
gonna do it anyway the answer for me is
I'm gonna make another video I'm gonna
try and push myself harder and I think
that's what Achievers do because
Achievers are failing more than you
because most days I get up and fail most
days I'm just feeling it's another
failure another failure another failure
but the more you fail the more you're
eventually gonna win
I'm gonna get massive results
because you tie yourself Worth to your
ability to get up and try again and try
again and try again and pat yourself on
the back for the effort you're putting
in not just when you're winning so how
do you do it I'm going to give you a
three-step process that I think will
help step number one is what I call the
pillow test this is my actual pillow
that when I'm in Toronto I sleep on
every single night and the pillow test
is make yourself proud before you hit
your head on the pillow right before you
go to sleep tonight before your head
hits your pillow you ask yourself am I
proud of my effort today not how much
did I win not did I get the results I
was looking for not that I get my
million views or close that big sale are
you proud of your effort are you proud
of your effort can you put your head on
your pillow tonight and say man I am
proud of the effort that I put in
that's the test that's the test for
tonight that's your test for tomorrow
night and the night after that and the
night after that and the night after
that and the more that you get a yes to
say yeah
heck yeah
heck yeah I'm proud of my effort you do
that you watch your business explode
step number two is expect to suck at the
start anytime you're trying something
new expect to suck don't expect to just
try something new and it's amazing
this is where a lot of people fall down
you've had some success you're at a
certain level you're going to try
something new before you go up you're
probably going to go down
that's part of the experimentation
process it doesn't mean you suck as a
human it just means that you don't have
the skill sets the talents yet you're
trying something new
I haven't brought props in on my videos
before that was a new test I expect it
to suck maybe on an off chance it works
amazing I learned from it but when
you're trying something it's brand new
you don't have the confidence in it yet
you're still figuring out the path
expect to suck when you put so much of
your worth into expecting to be great
the first time out here's what happens
you try one thing you record one video
you watch it back say man that sucked
and then you never make a video again
meanwhile if you just kept doing it it
would eventually be awesome you'd
eventually crush it go back and watch my
first videos go back go back to my main
Channel go back to the beginning see
where I started I've kept them all up so
you can see the journey the progress of
how much I sucked at the very beginning
it took me 350 videos until I wasn't
embarrassed by my content I was I was so
embarrassed I couldn't watch it back 350
videos but I kept going
the problem is people are quitting on
things too soon you quit on something
too soon because you're not getting
immediate results expect to suck it
doesn't mean that you suck as a human it
just means you don't have the skills yet
I had to get the skills by practicing
and number three is ask yourself what
would the most bold version of you do I
got this question was talking to my
video guy Danny who came to me with a
really important personal problem in his
life at the time and I said what would
the most bold version of you do it just
came out
[Music]
and anytime he doesn't know what to do
he asks himself that question what was
the most bold version of me do it's a
great question because it allows you to
push through a lot of your fears a lot
of your insecurities
to force yourself to be bold and you
want to be bold
you're meant to be bold
you're meant to create amazing wonderful
things you want that big vision of yours
to come true you are bold you are
courageous
but we don't live in that land very
often and so if you ask that question
what would the most bold version of you
do today
what it does is wash away a lot of those
fears and insecurities and gives you the
answer that you're actually looking for
rule number nine is fix your
relationships you are the product of the
five people that you spend the most time
with you've heard that before you know
it's important and the reason why it's
so true is because of a concept in
Persuasion in that whoever is more
confident wins whoever is more confident
in their opinion on something in their
habits on something is the one who wins
and persuades and influences other
people to join them even without having
to say anything just somebody being so
confident in their own negativity in
their own world and their own bad habits
without even telling you anything you
will naturally pick up on that thing and
dive down that same negative rabbit hole
with them and and that that's the fight
because if you are around people who are
negative who have the bad habits that
you don't want to have anymore it's not
that it's impossible but you're making
it a lot more challenging on yourself to
be able to pull yourself out of the hole
you are the result of the five people
that you spend the most time with so
let's say you want to work out you want
to work out you want to be healthy this
is the year you want to lose weight you
want to be in the best shape of your
life amazing right
but it's a new habit and this is the
problem at the very beginning of a new
habit if we go back to the concept of
persuasion
you don't have a lot of persuasion over
yourself yet you don't have a lot of
influence over yourself yet on this
habit because it's so new
so it's easy to get pulled in a million
different directions you're looking for
any possible reason why not to do it and
if you have a goal to go to the gym
every day or you have a goal to eat
healthy today
and then you see your friends around you
just diving in on Big Macs and lying on
the couch and complaining and being
negative
you can fight that
but at some point that fight starts to
wear down on you and your resolve isn't
strong enough yet because it's too new a
habit and so it's likely to happen is
you're gonna go join them because they
are more confident in their negative
approach than you are in the positive
approach they have such a history with
the bad habit
that then they influence you to go back
down that negative path I remember
hanging out with a very popular YouTuber
and uh he was asking well how do I grow
even to the next step and I'm I love how
consistent you are he's talking about my
channel how consistent I was and when I
was
with him over dinner
one of the things that I struggled with
was when I travel I usually let my diet
go you know I'm traveling having fun I
don't have my usual routine and so not
that I would just smash Doritos down my
face but I would just eat whatever and
he was at a restaurant with me and he
was eating really clean he had a fish
and salad and no dressing and just
really really clean and was waking up
the next day he was gonna go for a run
some of those habits are what I do here
when I'm at home but I don't do it when
I travel and so here he was admiring how
consistent I was on making videos and
having however many thousands of videos
now on the channel and I was admiring
how consistent he was in his eating
healthy and his working out now what
would happen if we started to hang out
more
if we started to hang out more and we
look at those two things the consistency
on making videos and the staying healthy
on the consistency of making videos I am
so
it's just part of me now I'm so
confident in my making videos and that I
have to get it done that even if he was
lying on the couch all day not that he
would but even if he was he wouldn't
negatively influence me so I would suck
him to making more videos he would be
making more videos as a result of
hanging out with me it would just
naturally happen without me even saying
anything to him because here's what
would happen he might be on the couch he
might be getting distracted might be
doing something else I said okay man I
gotta go make videos and by me going off
and making videos it will motivate him
to go make more videos I don't have to
say anything your actions speak way
louder than your words don't tell
somebody to go do something you want to
influence and persuade them go do the
thing and they'll see you doing it now
it's in their environment and it's gonna
suck them in so if we hung up together
he would be more consistent on the
content
on the other hand if we hung out
together consistently
I would get healthier with my my travel
diet if I traveled every time with him
then we would likely eat at more healthy
restaurants he would likely be working
out every morning I would likely join
him on some of those he would just
pull me towards being a healthier
traveler compared to what I am now
because he is so confident in that habit
that he's trying to build and so where
we struggle as entrepreneurs is we're
trying to build these new habits we're
trying to pull ourselves up to a better
brighter future better place more proud
of ourselves but we're still stuck with
the people around us who are in a
negative environment who want to stay
stuck who just complain about where they
are instead of actually trying to build
something better for themselves so if
that remains your friend's Circle in the
next five years it's going to be really
really challenging for you to get to the
place where you want to be okay well
that's that's great Evan how do I change
it I mean I don't want to just leave my
friends I don't even know where to get
new friends how do I start this process
there are three big strategies I want to
give you that I think will really really
help first off you don't have to go off
and tell all your friends hey you guys
suck I'm better than you I don't want to
hang out with you anymore
right so step one is just do an audit
just do an audit of your friends just do
an audit of the five people that you
spend the most time with just think
about it in the past two months who have
you spent the most time with and then
how many of them make you feel better
about yourself where you leave them
feeling more bold more confident more
excited for your life more ready to go
and take on the big challenges that are
ahead of you and hand me them make you
feel worse how many of them you have to
go home and have a nap or how many of
them you just feel drained as a result
of talking to them not that they're bad
people they're just in a lot of pain
right again I don't think like there are
toxic people I just think that they're
in a lot of pain and and hurt people
hurt people right so if you're not
strong enough yet to influence them
they're gonna suck you down so step one
is to do an audit of your friends step
two is to limit access to the people who
are making you feel worse about yourself
again it doesn't mean you have to go and
tell them that they suck just just stop
spending time together
as you spend less time together you find
that the relationship just kind of
Fizzles away you don't have to have some
big conversation just kind of access
spend less time go out once a month
instead of once a week call them less
frequently stop doing things together
you'll just notice that as you spend
less time together
you stop getting influenced so
negatively people are so afraid of
breaking off a friendship because you
think you have to have this really tough
conversation you don't
you don't you just have to spend less
time with them just look at your
calendar and see how often you usually
spend and your goal for next month is to
spend half the amount of time or a
quarter the amount of time that you
spent with them as last month that's it
that's step two it doesn't have to be
some big break doesn't have to be crazy
scary doesn't have to be overwhelming
and massively painful
three is it going to be to fill the void
so if you stop spending time with people
two things happen one you get a this
void it's like well who do I spend time
with now I have this extra time in my
calendar I've got these blocks and the
other thing is you start to feel lonely
you know if you don't have that friend
circle around you anymore it's easy to
feel lonely which is maybe even worse
than spending time with them at least
you have some kind of connection we're
settling for just okay relationships
because we crave the connection because
you just want to have somebody around
you because it's better to be with that
person than it is to be alone
and that's the biggest fear is that
you're just gonna end up alone that
you'll never find anybody
even in romantic relationships but also
in your friendships because it can be
harder as you get older to join friend
circles to make new friends is why a lot
of people are still stuck with the same
friends they had in high school and
University because they never actually
went to go out and search for new
friends because it's so afraid that
you're gonna be stuck alone so in that
vacuum in that void in that hole in your
calendar now what are you gonna do well
the goal is to now meet new people and
you don't have to treat it like it's
dating it's a relationship you just go
off to the events and the and the people
that you
feel like you might have a connection to
so I'm introverted I'm shy I am not a
people person I hate networking events I
hate small talk
and so how I would do it if you're
extroverted it's super easy just go and
go to the events and hang out and say hi
and say hi I'm Evan good to meet you I
would never I never go up to anybody and
say hi I'm Evan it's great to meet you
what do you do I just I never do that
um so the easy way to do it is think
about the clubs the activities and the
events that are really interesting for
you that it's a lot more natural for you
to have a conversation about so if there
was just a business networking meeting I
would hate that I hate that kind of
stuff well you have to explain what it
is that you do and they don't really
care or interested in but finding common
Hobbies
so for me
I would pick entrepreneurship I would
pick League of Legends I would pick
salsa dancing and signing into Minecraft
so maybe maybe some Minecraft I would
pick something in those four areas where
I could easily connect with people that
it doesn't feel like a chore to talk
about because I love that topic as a
quick example
um I was on an airplane and I was flying
to Brighton burchard's event in Puerto
Rico and so I was I was one of two
external speakers coming in to speak at
the event and this is his high level
Mastermind these are people who are
paying 30 to 50 000 to be in that room
and I'm flying down there and I you know
I'm in business class there's only one
person next to me and he's trying to
strike up a conversation and I I just I
just don't like it it's like so where
are you going like well we're going to
Puerto Rico like where are you coming
from I'm from Toronto and he was coming
up from Vancouver and I just I hate the
small talk right I hate the small talk
and so I think he kind of noticed after
a couple tries that I wasn't really
interested in talking to him I didn't
mean to be rude I just it doesn't
fulfill me I'd rather just be by myself
and alone and focus on what I need to
talk about and so we're flying down
there
and I don't really know why he's going
or what you know what he's going for
what his business is in Puerto Rico if
he's speaking if he's got an event what
so we don't really talk for the rest of
the way not anything rude just we're in
our own world
I get there and get in my uh my taxi or
Uber or whatever and drive to the hotel
where we're staying
and as I'm checking in guess who shows
up right behind me
right next to me on the counter the same
guy that I spent all this time now just
sitting next to not talking to on the
airplane
and he said hey you're here too it's
like and as soon as I knew that he was
here for Brendan burchard's event it's
like yeah man are you here too oh my God
what's your business
as soon as I found out that he was an
entrepreneur it's it's way easier to
have a connection and so we spent a
little more time there chatting spent a
couple a couple of moments over the over
the course of the conference as well but
it's so much easier to make connections
when you have a joint interest right if
I know you're an entrepreneur or I know
you care about League of Legends or
Minecraft or salsa dancing if I know any
of those things we are instantly going
to be friends and have something to talk
about
but if you're just a normal human who
maybe I don't know anything about then
it's a lot more difficult so
because you have this vacuum and you
don't know who to connect with and you
want to feel that connection and
belonging with the group
don't let that hole and that pain drag
you back to the circle that you know
doesn't ultimately support you and look
for the events that are exciting for you
to go to for the clubs for the
activities that you are generally like
oh that'd be so cool to be able to go
there and you'll end up meeting
like-minded people and that becomes your
new friend Circle and when that happens
when you hold on to good people like
that you actually stop even caring that
some of the people
you know I've kind of drifted or you've
let go of at some point instead of
spending once a month with them now
maybe it's once a year just catching up
or maybe you don't talk again not again
because you've had some conversation and
they hate you you've just Grown Apart
and the last time you spend with
somebody the more you're gonna grow
apart you are the product of the five
people that you hang out with the most
you've heard it before you'll hear it
again when is the time to actually take
the action do the audit of your friend's
Circle do they make you feel better
about yourself or Worse about yourself
stop spend as much time with the people
that make you feel worse about yourself
and then feel the void fill the vacuum
with people who lift you up by going to
events and clubs and activities that you
genuinely care about it's not just a
strategy to make connections but you
love being there you will meet some
amazing like-minded people I'm rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is control your
addictions you are where you are because
of you because of the choices you've
made because of the mindset that you
have because of the lack of
accountability you are where you are
because of you and that is a very tough
message to hear but it's also a very
liberating and freeing message to hear
because it's so comfortable and so so
easy to blame other people we just we
would love to blame other people you
know we would love it's so easy to say
well I'm here because of my parents you
know or I'm here because of the country
that I was born in or I'm stuck here
because of the president and the and the
policies that the president put into
place I'm here because of XYZ whatever
story happened to you right it's so much
easier to stay stuck in blaming other
people
because it means we don't have to do
anything
because it means that it's not your
responsibility to fix it like it makes
sense this is why you're stuck right
like oh well this is why if I had this
set up for me then then of course it'd
be more successful you know if my
parents were like this and of course
it'd be more successful
it takes the accountability and the
responsibility off of your shoulders
and that's a very comforting message but
it keeps you stuck
[Music]
it keeps you staying exactly where you
are it keeps you in slow growth or no
growth mode
where when you can flip it to I'm here
because of me
and I will end up in a different spot
because of me that where I start right
now is not where I'm gonna finish
that where I am right now
is not going to be where I end up
because of the actions that I'm going to
take
one important
thought that I want to get across in
this video is there is a very big
difference between taking accountability
and placing blame
what want to do is blame we want to
blame others
and we don't want to blame ourselves
I'm not asking to blame yourself blaming
doesn't do anything
blaming is still negative thinking
blaming is still
being stuck in the past
you're sitting there even blaming
yourself you're stuck in a path oh I
should have done this how many times
have you done that how many times have
you done that I should have done this I
should have been more proactive I should
have taken that chance when I had when I
had the opportunity I should have asked
that question I should have started that
business three years ago I should have I
should have I should have right you're
blaming yourself that's not what this is
taking accountability is not blaming
yourself for all your past mistakes
because if you're stuck in blaming
blaming others or blaming yourself you
stay stuck still too you're in a really
negative
mindset and you say stuck and don't do
anything that's not what this is what
this is is saying I don't want to stay
stuck here and the difference is going
to be me taking accountability for my
life
so how do we how do we start to get
there
let me share a couple pointers okay
number one
find some Heroes
[Music]
chances are wherever you look up to
whoever your hero is
whether it's Oprah Winfrey Kevin O'Leary
Richard Branson Steve Jobs whoever your
hero is
your hero probably started with less
than what you have right now
less money
less support less Freedom less
opportunities
they started with less than what you
have right now
so how did they break free like how did
they get out of the situation that they
were in the bigger hole that they were
in compared to the hole that you're in
how did they get out
[Music]
because that not only gives you strategy
but also gives you the hope and
motivation to recognize well if this
person could do it from a worse
situation to what I'm in right now
the difference is they didn't stay stuck
in the blame game
they took responsibility and they got
out you can too
surround yourself with Heroes
whether that's watching YouTube videos
whether that's reading books listening
to podcasts but be around your Heroes
because they have a different mindset
most people do not take responsibility
or accountability they don't we don't
want to because it's the harder path we
want to take the easy way out so the
people you're listening to the people
who are around you the people who are in
your life right now likely are not the
ones saying I'm responsible for my life
and I'm gonna go fix it right
around you are doing the opposite to say
no I'm this this person's fault
so we have to start to shift that you
have to be around your Heroes more so
who are the people you look up to you
respect you love the most that has the
mindset that you want to have the belief
that you want to have the confidence
that you want to have who are those
people
and then surround yourself with them
more subscribe to more YouTube channels
the right YouTube channels follow more
people on Instagram the right people
like do a real audit of the people that
you're hanging out with even virtually
right garyvee or Elon Musk might not
come and Mentor you personally but you
can learn a lot from them from their
content from their interviews from their
books from their podcasts from their
shows you can learn a lot from them if
you choose to surround yourself with
them so do an audit of who you follow on
Instagram of who you follow on YouTube
do an audit and see how many of these
people make you feel better about
yourself give you hope ambition courage
that when you watch their stuff you
consume their stuff you're around it you
leave feeling better if you're scrolling
through Instagram and you close it and
you feel worse about yourself it's your
responsibility to fix that because
there's lots of people you could follow
who give you motivation inspiration hope
courage momentum action
YouTube as well you could die down and
watch eight hours of YouTube and then
feel terrible about yourself because you
just got distracted we're entertaining
yourself you were consumed by negative
content you can switch that unsubscribe
from all those people
and start to follow more channels that's
why I make so much content holy cow how
much content do I make every day I don't
know across all the channels there's so
much content but you know what it's
always positive it's always spreading
belief it's always filled with hope
you'll never see videos on my channel
talking about how terrible somebody is
or how we should cancel this person or
how bad the world is right and whether
you love my content grade or somebody
else is awesome but most important is
the feeling you have about yourself
because when you're filled with hope
confidence courage Your Life totally
changes so step number one is you have
to be around your Heroes step number two
to starting to take responsibility is
what's the action that you can do today
you know what can you do today to start
building some momentum if you accept
that hate
it's not my fault where I'm at but it's
my responsibility to fix it right it's
not your fault
it's not blame
but it's your responsibility to change
it for yourself and for others that you
can change it that you could be the one
you could be the Difference Maker where
this all starts to change
right what is that immediate momentum
you need to take do you need to launch
your own YouTube channel do you need to
start writing your book you need to
create your program you need to get on
stage and speak you need to launch that
service or product do you need to do
that collaboration like what's what's
the what's the next step
because the biggest thing that's missing
for most people is just momentum you've
got the ideas and the hard and the drive
and the and the love and the care and
the desire to do good and you want to
serve and you want to make money and you
want to build it but you want all these
things great but what's the momentum
that's happening
what's the next step
to get you out of the hole
and then number three is just scheduling
that in because no matter how bold and
confident and ambitious you feel right
now this is a process that takes time
and you can do
a lot in one day but we tend to
overestimate what we can do in in a day
and underestimate what we can do
you know in a year or in two years or in
five years
so the difference is going to be the
actual momentum that we start taking
consistently so you have one great day
today amazing what's happening tomorrow
what's happening the next day and it's
creating a calendar that you can stay
consistent on
you don't have to stay stuck
where you are in one year can be a
totally different spot than where you
are right now
the difference is not beating yourself
up not blaming yourself for the people
around you not saying how much people
screwed you over and just keep on
thinking about the negative things that
happen to you growing up
and instead saying you know what
it's my responsibility to fix this
I'm taking accountability from my life
and I refuse to be stuck in the same
spot one year from today
eighty percent of our inner dialogue is
negative and 95 of those thoughts are
the same thoughts that we had yesterday
that's what Beth Handel taught me she's
garyvee's life coach we had an awesome
session together and it really hit home
imagine that 80 percent of the thoughts
that you've got eighty percent
are negative we are beating ourselves up
we were telling ourselves that we can't
do things it's not even our friends and
family people around us telling us that
we suck it's us it's ourselves we tell
ourselves we're not good enough we can't
do this we're not strong enough smart
enough we're from the wrong country we
look the wrong way you know we're too
young we're too old whatever it is 80 of
our thoughts are negative and then 95 of
those negative thoughts are the exact
same negative thoughts that we had
yesterday it's no wonder why we stay
small it's no wonder why we stay stuck
because we've created this reinforcing
Loop of negativity this is why I think
the world's biggest problem is lack of
belief you know I'm I'm on a mission
every day wake up try to make content
try to spread the message to help people
believe in themselves more I think lack
of belief is the single biggest problem
in the world
and I also believe that everybody has
Michael jordan-level genius at something
like you are the greatest you're the
greatest in the world at something and
it's not what you went to school for and
it's not what your parents did for a
living probably it's something
completely different and you have to
have the courage to go off and Chase it
and find it and and do it because the
woman who solves cancer should have
already solved it by now but she never
believed in herself enough to go to
medical school and now she's a manager
and accounting firm which doesn't like
her life right I mean this is this is
where most of us are stuck most people
wake up and they drive their job that
that we don't like most people are stuck
and barely hanging on and do not like
their life and feel like they're not
contributing they're not they're not
making any kind of difference they're
not doing anything meaningful or
impactful at all in the world that's
most people like imagine waking up and
that's your daily reality that may be
you
or that may have been who you were you
still describe it and trying to improve
and get better but if 80 of those
thoughts that come through your head
conscious or unconscious are negative I
think a lot of conscious thoughts are
negative too
not just the subconscious the conscious
thoughts are negative you telling
yourself that you can't do something and
you're not good enough and then 95 are
the same as yesterday that we've just
created this this Loop this negative
thinking Loop
so how do we break it how do we break
free how do we solve that problem well
that's that's the billion dollar
question and that's what I wake up
every day trying to fix and I can give
you a couple things that I've worked on
and I found helpful and hopefully helps
move the needle they don't have all the
answers but but some of these might help
the first one is to change your
environment the environment makes such a
huge difference for who you are and your
daily habits and what you believe about
yourself and the environment is not just
the people who are around you although
that definitely helps you know if you've
got negative friends or family around
you you want to eliminate them
completely or spend a lot less time with
them because it's really really really
hard to have a beautiful plant grow when
it's just you know toxic waste being
poured on top of them doable but really
really difficult and so changing that
can really help and
one of the best ways I found to do it is
content
it's content it's why I make so much
content for these channels that
hopefully
you wake up today and there's a piece of
content there waiting for you whether
it's me or showcasing somebody else
across all my channels we're making
multiple pieces of content every single
day to try to hit it in the right way
maybe today's message with the right
voice is the one that makes a difference
for you and if you can shift
the amount of entertainment you're doing
or just shutting off the world some of
the content that you consume just helps
you shut off the world and Escape versus
educational content that helps you learn
improve get better and solve the problem
right entertainment is let's forget
about the problem just laugh at
something else
education is let's learn to actually fix
the problem that is happening in our
life right I want to lean in on that a
lot more it doesn't mean that
entertainment doesn't exist in your life
it's not only education but if you can
shift the needle towards education to be
around the people who inspire you even
if you've never met them
it can really move the needle for your
your inner dialogue and your
self-confidence so the thing that saved
me in my first business in doing this
was modeling Bill Gates or Microsoft
when I I quit on my business partner I
struggled I didn't know you know I felt
worthless nothing was working I was
working every day and just no results in
in looking at Bill Gates's story that
that changed my life it saved my
business it allowed me to keep going
because now I had a little bit of hope
that if Bill Gates could do it maybe I
could too and the more you surround
yourself with those people
the more you'll feel like you can do it
too so do an audit how many people in
your life the the actual humans that you
know and also just the people that you
subscribe to that you follow how many of
them make you feel better about yourself
and for too many people it's it's not
enough you know it's it's look at who
you follow on YouTube look at who
subscribed to
um look at who you're connecting with on
Instagram you know if you're loading
your phone you're going through
Instagram or you're watching YouTube
videos how many times have you gone
through it and all of a sudden an hour
has gone by and you were mindlessly
watching videos or even worse make you
feel worse about yourself you ever felt
that you watch a video and then you feel
worse about yourself afterwards or
you're following somebody and it makes
you feel worse about yourself you have a
choice to unfollow those people this is
not Instagram's fault or YouTube's fault
you can take accountability here you
have a choice to unfollow those people
and then a choice to follow the people
who make you feel better about yourself
that's my aim with all these videos I
want to leave you with strategies but
also more belief in yourself at the end
of every video and if I do that I
awesome you want more belief in your
life come back you know another shot of
espresso tomorrow morning we're here and
if I don't do that cool thank you for
giving it a shot and and don't quit on
that go find somebody else who gives you
the motivation inspiration that you need
and so you can make a conscious choice
because it's so easy to stay stuck it's
so easy to stay small it's so easy to to
be the one that pours in other people
and not have anybody pour into us and
you need to make a conscious choice to
to raise your environment to change your
environment and it doesn't mean you have
to go move to a different country or
move to a fancier house or anything else
you start by just changing who you
associate with even at a mass scale
right
I've learned a lot from Steve Jobs I've
been inspired by Oprah Winfrey my
favorite entrepreneur of all time is AP
giannini who started Bank of America
these are people who I've never met
you know and and in the case of jobs in
Janine I never you know will meet
because they've passed
but I've been inspired by them and
they've made me better and they've
taught me and I've learned from them and
they've inspired me and I get courage
from them
because I've consumed their content
and you can do that too
it's just being intentional about it so
that when you raise your environment you
raise your life
the second thing is try not to do it
alone
it's really hard to go after
a goal to change your mindset to
accomplish big things when you're doing
it all by yourself you know
it this is why a lot of people quit
because you might have one one amazing
day or you watch The Right video you
have the right experience and it's like
that I wanna this is this is the life I
want you ever had that right like this
is the life that I want this is who I
want to be this is this is where I could
go you have a glimpse of a potential
future that you could be it's like I
want that and you actually feel in your
heart that you can be that you can
accomplish that right does that happen
to you and then what happens the next
day you wake up and it's kind of gone
and then the next day it's completely
gone and then you're back to your old
life and the limiting beliefs and the
habits and and you know you gain back
the 20 pounds and like how did I end up
back here I thought I fixed this right
does that ever happen to you
a lot of it is because you're doing it
alone
and this took me a long time to figure
out
as an introverted person as a shy person
as somebody who doesn't like asking for
help
um
as someone who's afraid of disappointing
people
being a part of a community is not
it just sounds super scary to me
we just did our seven day challenge for
built to serve and a bunch of people
join movement makers uh we had almost
100 people join Movie Makers at the end
of it and it's people who want to be
thought leaders and want to be speakers
and authors and coaches and course
creators and membership creators and all
of the stuff there's a big impact that
spread your message and I was giving
people
a lot of uh
not just encouragement but respect like
the people who ended up joining I just
had incredible respect for
because I wouldn't have done it if I go
back to 19 year old Evan when I started
my first business I wouldn't have done
it I wouldn't have had the courage to do
it I wouldn't have joined the group we
had people sharing their videos like
tell us about your your who your why
your how is your this methodology from
the book but make a video you know
sharing your purpose and your biggest
pain of all time and some of these you
know kind of deep uh things that you
have to record and share and I mean it
was optional not everybody did it but in
doing that
for a lot of people it was their first
video that they've ever done
for a lot of people it's the first time
they've even shared their story to
anybody that they were sharing things in
the group that they hadn't told their
spouse
you know or their family or their best
friend and now they're making a video
in their car
sharing their story
and you see them become liberated you
see them you see them start super scared
and Afraid and unsure and fixing their
hair and you know apologizing for the
lighting not being good and them being
in the car and not knowing what they're
doing to then just seeing the
transformation of somebody
going through the Cocoon you know being
a caterpillar and turn into a butterfly
and sharing their story for the first
time and I was in awe because I I
couldn't imagine me doing that at 19
when I started my first business
[Music]
I was too afraid to join a community I
was too afraid of being judged
I was too afraid of being not good
enough
and that kept me small
I kept my growth really slow
um fortunately I kept going you know if
you've seen my my
chart on my website where I show how
much I've grown every year over year
over year over year where I've been took
five years to get the 7 000 subscribers
or something like that
and I just kept going and the one thing
that I've got was just tenacity and
drive and I will just keep going in the
face of adversity
but I made it just incredibly hard on
myself being alone not being open to
sharing with my friends what I was
struggling with and never joining the
community
so I think that can really help you you
know I think I think trying to go and
change your mindset and accomplish big
things that nobody around you has done
yet and there are some days that you
feel incredibly inspired and motivated
and Powerful it's like yeah I can do
this but you're probably not living
there most of the time
what if you did or what if you lived
kind of close to that most of the time
in point number one of raising your
environment can definitely help
but Point number two is just don't try
to do it alone
even if it's one person you don't have
to join Movie Makers you have to join a
group
but even just one person
one person who you can talk to you can
connect with
who you can you know share your stories
with not just complain to not not talk
about how hard everything is and just
have somebody to vent to but somebody
who supports you
if you had a group of people who
supported you
well you felt welcome we felt like you
weren't alone on this journey we felt
like people understood you
and we're actually genuinely cheering
you on to go you know become the person
that you want to be
Everything Changes
so raise your environment
get a community and watch your impact
happen the free leads you to the paid if
you have no momentum no traction no
clients then start for free prove your
worth and build momentum give them
something they can't wait to have again
and pay for this time the goal isn't to
do free forever but the free gives you
the thing that you're missing the most
which is momentum in your business so
I'm pre-launching my book right now
built to serve and people who buy the
book and pre-order also get access to my
private Facebook group where I help
people one-on-one every week and so the
guy that I had on last week is a coach
he's a health coach he wants to help
people make transformations to their
health because he made a radical shift
in his health as well and I said great
well how are you doing right now well I
have a couple clients but I'm still
working at a restaurant I want to be
able to leave that so I can focus on
this full-time awesome if you're a coach
what I need to see you is coaching I
need to see you coaching people what I'd
love to see now is an Instagram live
regular show and what do you do on your
Instagram live you bring on people who
need help being coached through a health
transformation because it's one thing to
say I'm a coach and I help people get
these results it's another though to
actually see people change to have you
go live with them one-on-one and help
them bust through their limiting beliefs
and their mindset and the issues that
they're dealing with and then they come
out on the other side by the end of the
call feeling hope feeling invigorated
feeling inspired because people will
watch that and say man
I want a result like that they see
themselves in the client that you're
helping and they then want it for
themselves now you get two versions one
will be free people
one would be like can you do me I I'll
take it for free
which is great don't say no don't get
discouraged don't get upset you want the
free because the free gives you the
content and so if they're willing to
come on and do live on Instagram with
you for free then you do it
and there'll be other people who say hey
I love what you're doing I need a
radical transformation in my health as
well but I don't want to be on Instagram
I don't want to make it public can I can
I hire you privately
Bingo right that's what we're looking
for that's when you start getting paid
the free leech to the paid whatever it
is that you want to get known for
whatever it is you want to start making
money with show it to me publicly for
free and if other people want it
publicly for free as well then it's a
yes especially at the beginning when you
have no momentum and no clients and
you're working some job that you hate
yes for free yes one you get better at
it because the more you do the better
you'll get and two You're Building
momentum and people start talking about
you
and then you get the people who will see
it and say I want that person I want to
I want to hire that person and any
repeat people they want more they want
coaching session number two it's paid
here's how much it costs the free leads
you to the paid so how can you do it I'm
going to give you a three-step process
that you can follow step number one is
think who can you help who specifically
can you help like who are the people
that you want to help so for me it'd be
entrepreneurs if you are a makeup artist
and you're just doing it for yourself or
you have some job that you hate and you
have no no aspiration of being an
entrepreneur I I might be able to help
you a little bit but it's not my core
audience I want to help entrepreneurs
who are the people specifically that you
want to be helping so in the case of the
guy who was in my Insider's group he
started off yesterday and he was a
transformational coach okay great but
that's that could be anything a
transformation everybody needs a
transformation everybody the whole world
needs a transformational coach who
because if you can't tell me exactly who
it is that you helped then I can't I
can't think of who I can refer you to
you're making it too difficult on people
if you serve everybody then you serve
nobody so who are you helping he's like
well I love helping people who need a
big transformational change in their
health because that was me awesome now
it's more specific step number two is
what specifically will you do how do you
help are you gonna are you gonna coach
me through a process you're gonna
meditate with me you're going to give me
you know a product that that will help
me what specifically will you do and so
with my friend who was in the group he
was saying that he he wants to do
coaching calls he coaches people they
don't have to be face to face it can be
anywhere in the world as long as you can
see them right so that's specifically
what you do you have your methodology
you have your steps makes you seem like
an expert and you kind of know what
you're doing right you create your own
methodology say here is how I can help
people get a result from the problem
that they're coming in with and in Step
number three is think how can you make
it public you need them to get a result
you need this specific person with this
problem to come in you're going to help
them you're going to help them get a
result and I want to see them get a
result and then how can you make it
public so that other people can see it
too so that it's not just you talking
about how you had this great result but
it's them in a public forum so I can if
I see them getting a result I'm going to
think I'm just like that person too
I want to contact you and hire you and
bring you on board my team because I
want for me what you just did to that
person so who can you help what
specifically can you do and then how can
you make it public you can change the
negative patterns that I run in your
life
the patterns that you think are
impossible to break that have been with
you for life that will be with you for
the rest of your life you can break them
it starts with a decision and if you
don't want to still be in 20 years
living by that same negative pattern
that is holding you back
I think this video will help most of
what we do is subconscious most of what
we do is beneath the surface most of
what we do is
what we've been conditioned to do and
the patterns that we've seen and you
know if you're watching this you're
likely an adult and we've been running
the same pattern programming for a
number of years if not decades and
it can be really difficult to be able to
switch that pattern but I'm going to
give you a formula today that I think
will really help and one that I'm
applying myself as well in my life so
step one
is even just acknowledging that the
pattern exists and that you want to make
a change
what is to happen
what is the negative Loop that's in your
mind what is the thing that you don't
want to still be thinking
in the next year two years five years
ten years what is that thing one of the
things that I'm working on is moving to
a space of great things happen to me I
had a great video coaching session with
Beth hendel and my big aha moment that
came from there was
I believe in the plan
so whenever I am thinking of something I
make a plan and then I execute the plan
and I do the plan and I follow the plan
and when I don't believe in the plan
then I create a new plan then I believe
in that plan and that's the thing that
gets me going so I'm very plain schedule
calendar oriented that gives me my
security that gives me my identity and
so as long as I have a plan easy peasy
let's go we're waking up we're making
videos because it's in the plant
but then what happens on the rare days
you know maybe once a month where
I don't believe in the plan anymore I
don't think the plan is good enough to
get to where I want to go
and I can't make a new plan I don't know
what the next plan should be what I have
done so that I don't get lost and
spiraled down into negative thinking
into uh maybe not depression but
anxiety and stress and overwhelm that I
don't know what to do next you ever been
faced with that like I don't know what
to do next
my plan has been my plan today I'm using
the words
just to tell myself
great things happen to me this is what
I've done it's been my coping mechanism
the the way out of the stress and the
anxiety and not knowing what to do next
is me telling myself great things happen
to me
and what Beth challenged me to do
and the big Insight that came from it
was living not in the identity of the
plan but living in the great things
happened to me so now I'm trying to
shift my identity from being the guy who
believes in the plan to being the guy
who believes that great things happen to
me that instead of using great things
happen to me just as a coping mechanism
on my worst days the once a month days
when I really don't believe that I'm I'm
getting closer to my goals or I'm never
going to hit them
and flipping that to being the default
mode that's that's really hard I've I've
was not born the plan guy it took me
decades I'm 42 coming up in May I'm 42
and it took me decades to become the
plan guy you know two decades to become
the planned guy
and now I'm I'm not
getting rid of the plan guy thank you
plan guy you got me here I appreciate
you you know Pat in the back I still
need you please stay with me on this
journey but I want to be the guy who
believes the great things are coming
because at the end of the day all your
great things all your great ideas all
your great breakthroughs usually don't
come as a result of the plan
it's maybe a byproduct of the plan but
not a direct result of the plan because
the plan only is something that you know
exists right now it's it's what I've
talked about making decisions with your
head versus your heart big decision with
your heart song with the head the head
only understands the world that
currently exists where your heart can
create something brand new and so I want
to be I want to be in the brand new I
want to create something that hasn't
been done before and so the you can't
plan for something that hasn't been done
before and you need to have some faith
that great things will happen and so
that's a long way of me saying that I am
trying to become
the guy who believes that great things
happen to me as a default state
I believe that when I say that when I
create video and I say that on camera or
when I'm talking I believe that I
believe the great things come to me if I
keep going if I keep making if I keep
sharing if I leave with my heart if I
tap into what I feel is the right thing
to do even if it doesn't make sense I
believe that great things will happen
and I've seen enough of that happen over
my life and career that I believe it and
if you're not quite there yet
just look for some small wins that when
you have help when you have shared when
you have created from the heart you've
gotten some small wins and if you keep
going you can have
slightly bigger ones and medium-sized
winds and then large ones and then
gigantic wins if you just keep going so
how do I shift and we're working through
this in real time I'm not sharing a
story that is you know
it's 20 years old like I sometimes might
do the foundation story so how do I
shift how do I shift from being
the plan guy to the great things will
happen to me Kai I think it could be
useful
Mini case study for you if there's
something that you want to work on
that you want to improve at you're tired
of telling yourself a different story
and you want to shift it so here's what
I'm doing first off is trigger words
right so if I say plan that's a trigger
word plan ooh plan here's my plan plan I
said it again not that it's bad right
for years it might be bad it might be it
might be a critical you telling yourself
that you're stupid or that you can't or
it can't it could be another a trigger
word or hard it's another trigger word
the fact that you're not going to do
something because it's hard that's a
trigger word right so what are the
trigger words that you tell yourself as
to why you can't do something or that
keep you locked in your negative
patterns what are those trigger words so
anytime you catch it you say it you feel
it you tell somebody else it that like
oh there it is again I'm noticing it and
you could tell the people in your life
your your family your friends your
spouse people on your team you can tell
them
hey if I ever say this word I want you
to I want you to call me out in it so
you can have people kind of support you
through this journey as well number two
is you try to design in a conscious way
applying it in your life consistently so
the next thing I did as soon as I got
off that coaching call with Beth was I
told Nina I told my wife and I said hey
great things happen to us I told her
what happened and great things happened
to us great things happened to us great
things happen to us and I honestly I
must say that at least 40 times a day
great things happen to me talking to
myself or great things happen to us
if you want you can set it as a alarm in
your phone you could put it as the
background on your on your computer
screen you can put it as a sticky note
on the bathroom mirror or the door I
have a email that I sent myself that I
didn't delete out of my inbox so so I
always see it in my inbox every day when
I'm checking my email I check my email
once a day and it's always the last
email that I that I checked because I
never removed from my inbox and it says
this is your great things happen to
reminder
yeah
this is your great things happen to your
reminder every time oh that's right
great things happen to me because that's
still not it's nowhere close to being my
default
but I'm working towards becoming that
person
so it's the decision to do it and then
with intention putting things into your
calendar so that it happens so again
maybe you're setting an alarm on your
phone maybe you're putting the picture
up on your wall uh you're telling your
friends and the people around you and
you're finding a way to repeat it to
repeat it to repeat it to repeat it and
I'm not judging myself as to I need to
get this done next week
I just want to make a little bit of
progress every day Beth's team reached
out and wanted to do a round two of
coaching and I said I'm still I mean
thank you it's amazing I'm still working
on the last thing you know the great
things happen to me
shift in mindset is something that I'm
working through and
it's incredibly powerful and I don't
think I need any help for anything else
yet I'm still working through this thing
this week has been a really challenging
week for Anita and myself as well we are
we ran our build to serve challenge
which which was crazy
um when we first did it the the idea
that was pitched to me was seven days 45
minutes to an hour each day and we ended
up going the seven days and you know
three to four hours each day which I
didn't budget for but it was amazing
helping thought leaders and speakers and
coaches and entrepreneurs authors
just the energy and the vibe and the
love was so amazing that it took up an
incredible amount of time at the same
time we just bought a a brand new house
which is super exciting and so selling
this place and so I had to move my up
you might notice it's a different
background than usual I'm not I guess I
could have done it in my car
um but I'm not in my usual Studio my
office because we have a makeshift
office while we get our place ready to
list today
so we're packing and moving and
switching all the artwork and all of
that stuff while running a challenge uh
yesterday I hit the side of a a curb
that had a rock
not a rock like a boulder and it
punctured my tire and not just like
giant hole in my tire uh so okay we have
to go and get the car fixed on top of
everything else which is why I can't
film in the in the car like I normally
do because I don't have a car right now
because it's being fixed because we I
blew out the tire and just issue over
issue over issue and
my niece was with us yesterday
and she made a comment to my wife Nina
about how calm we were through
everything like okay well the car tire
got blown out uh that's that completely
changes how we spend the rest of today
now instead of doing these errands and
taking people here and all of this stuff
on Nina's birthday by the way
it's like okay well here's what we need
to do now you know okay we gotta get
fixed we gotta figure out how to solve
these other problems and let's go and
she was my niece was blown away but how
we weren't arguing or fighting or
yelling or
uh super stressed just okay let's solve
the problem and keep moving on with our
day why because great things happen to
us
great things happen to us and that's you
know when something negative going on
even if it doesn't feel real
it'll be something that Nina and I will
laugh over great things happen to us oh
that happened okay great great thing you
know what great things happen to us
we will figure out a way through this
great things happen to us and in that
ongoing conditioning
the more that it's around us the more
that I say it I believe it a little bit
more and a little bit more and a little
bit more and a little bit more and I
guess you could call it affirmations I
never really
connected to affirmations that much
because it felt
if I was saying something that I didn't
believe in that
that it wouldn't it wouldn't work for me
and because I already believed that it
wouldn't work for me then I've already
set myself up for feeling from the
beginning I think the key thing is if
you want to be able to change that
mindset you want to change the Habit
Loop you have to find something that you
actually on your best days believe
there's a kernel of Truth in there right
if you're 400 pounds you say I'm skinny
I'm skinny I'm skinny I think I think a
lot of
in your head you say well that's BS I'm
not skinny and and then you don't
there's no even kernel of truth to it so
then you never do the actions to help
you get there
where on your best days what do you
believe about yourself on your best days
how do you handle problems
so when I say great things happen to me
I believe it
I actually believe that that wasn't
something that was given to me that
wasn't something that somebody once told
me that wasn't somebody that a coach
told me that okay you have to use this
now as your Mantra I believe it on my
best days I believe it I believe it I
can I can tap into that and I believe it
there's a kernel of truth to it and I
want to make that kernel you know grow
into something much much much much
bigger so homework would be to think
about
on your best days what do you believe
about yourself what what's the specific
language the specific words that you
would say to yourself to encourage
yourself or you're looking back and
you're proud of yourself on your best
days what do you believe about yourself
and then finding a way to make that a
daily part of your life
so that when the negative things come
you can tell yourself this as a reminder
and it starts to shift everything for
you the fastest way to achieve your
goals is to model the people who've
already achieved the same goals that you
have model success success excludes the
famous expression and it's true people
have already figured out the thing that
you are struggling to figure out and the
more you are stuck trying to come up
with every idea yourself the harder
you're making it on yourself and this is
man this is one of the two fundamental
lessons that I have learned in my life
my life that has saved my life and my
business my first company I learned this
lesson first and I was 20 years old out
of desperation where I was making no
money and struggling and I quit on my
business partner I quit you know like I
can't keep going I quit
and I modeled Bill Gates I just asked
myself who has done this before model
Bill Gates put it to work had some
success I've told the story many times
but it's important because that was the
thing that saved me that's that's what
saved my company you know in modeling
Bill Gates and how we started Microsoft
that's what saved my business and
allowed me to keep going and I'm I'm now
here you know if I didn't do that I'd
probably have some job that I'm not
happy with
20 years later still stuck in the same
job that I'm not happy with and that
idea
came to me at a moment of desperation
it's not even the smartest idea right I
mean I wasn't into personal development
I wasn't reading books I didn't I didn't
know anything and I wish I had somebody
guide me or Mentor me and it's a very
basic idea model success you know I wish
I'd watch videos like this I wish they
were available when I was 19 20 years
old it really just came out of moment of
desperation where I'm at my parents home
crying my face off because I just quit
on this business that I cared about and
I didn't want to fail but I felt there
was no option I just felt overwhelmed
frustrated it just was not working out
and
everything felt lost
and it was only in that absolute moment
of Crisis that I thought maybe somebody
else has done this before we're up until
that point I felt like I had to come up
with every idea myself like oh maybe we
should do this maybe we should do that
maybe we could try this and nothing
would seem to be working and it wasn't
until I asked that question then I found
Bill Gates and how he started Microsoft
and that's what started turning the
company around whatever problem you're
facing right now it's been addressed
many many many many times by many many
many many many many successful people
your job becomes to find out who they
are and to go back and study how they
how they solve that problem and it's
really important to figure out how they
solve the exact problem that you're
struggling with right now so what I told
myself when I was looking at Bill Gates
was
I don't care how Bill Gates makes an
extra million dollars right now how did
he get started how do you go from zero
to one what was the thing that that
built this company up and for all these
people the bigger they are the easier it
is to research their story Bill Gates
only came to mind because I had a
software company and I just said who's
built a software company it was not
even that structured or thought out or
in depth or or you know in detail he was
the first guy that I thought of that had
a software company Bill Gates Microsoft
how do you do it that was it
and in looking at a story I found out
that Microsoft built their business
through Partnerships
and their big deal came when they made a
partnership with IBM and IBM at the time
was the biggest computer manufacturer on
the planet so the deal was every IBM
that was shipped every computer that was
shipped from the biggest computer
manufacturer in the world had Microsoft
software on it it was a huge deal that
blew up the company and that was pretty
easy to find right the transitional
moment in the company
it's like wow okay Partnerships that's
interesting I mean we can do that but
Microsoft was already a seven million
dollar company when they made that deal
now 7 million was nothing compared to
whether they would go on to be right
billions and billions of dollars but
it was seven million dollars it was
still more than what I had
right seven million dollars felt like a
giant company compared to me making 300
bucks a month right so the next layer is
to dig a Little Deeper
not just their big break which is
important but how do they get started
like how did they get to The Big Break
is really valuable it's really helpful
to figure out and again the bigger the
person is that you're modeling the
easier it is to find the content you
just might have to dig you might have to
go read biographies read articles read
interviews watch videos to figure out
those early Parts not their just their
upbringing but what were the things that
they did that led to the big
breakthrough not just what the big
breakthrough was big breakthrough is
super important but the steps that led
to the brick big breakthrough even more
important if you're at the beginning
getting started so Microsoft big
breakthrough was the IBM deal they're
already seven million dollar company how
do they get to become a seven million
dollar company that was the million
dollar question maybe the seven million
dollar question and it was still through
Partnerships
so what Microsoft did was they had
software and they looked at any hardware
that existed
that needed software for it and they
would go in and Pitch their software
their first deal was with the mitz
Altair and
uh the mid-tal tear was a was a piece of
hardware and it was featured on the
cover of uh of their magazine that was
the big magazine for the computer
industry at the time and they needed
software and Bill Gates and uh called
them up with his partner Paul Allen and
said hey we've got software for the
mid-tal tear that you can use that will
make it a lot more valuable valuable to
people and they didn't even have it
built yet
on the on the on the plane ride over to
go meet the company Bill Gates was
finishing up the code to go program and
they hope that it would work and luckily
it did when they when they had the
meeting uh so I don't I don't
necessarily like that part of lying that
you've got something but it's
interesting to know how he did it the
the boldness the the willingness to
reach out and say hey I've got something
that can help you we're things that I
really struggled with as a 19 year old
entrepreneur believing that what I had
was great then I could really solve big
problems where Bill Gates was saying
yeah we got this even though he didn't
have it yet and he wrote it on the plane
on the on the way over right but it was
still through Partnerships and anytime
Microsoft was entering something new
they found Partnerships and so I applied
that strategy to me and I started
looking for who can who can we partner
with not like a business partner where
they own a piece of our company but who
can we partner with that is a
distribution deal
and the first uh company that I
made a deal with was out of the UK and
we had a arrangement for them to
represent us in the UK in a couple of
the markets in Europe where they would
be Distributing our product and we made
an exclusive deal so that anytime we got
a lead from those markets it would go to
them and they would be doing their own
marketing promotion as well and in
exchange for that exclusive partnership
they would pay us thirteen and a half
thousand dollars up front
and I remember I was I was so scared to
ask for that it felt like a giant number
what if they said no this big potential
deal and uh and they said yes they said
yes and we had we had money in our bank
account
for the first time which was wild and
crazy and
that was a fantastic deal for us and
more important is it it said it gave us
hope which is Mega important to give us
momentum which is Mega important and it
gave us a model to keep following and so
what I what I ended up doing after which
was let's go get more partnership deals
let's go get more partnership deals and
the people who ended up buying us was
basically a partnership deal so instead
of partnering with our company they just
bought the whole business
and that's how we exited all because of
modeling Bill Gates when I quit on my
company so whatever
problem you're facing personal or
business people have solved it humans
have been around for a long time
somebody has solved this problem you do
not have to be a genius and come up with
every new idea yourself can your
creativity and love and Panache help yes
of course
but you don't have to have the seed for
every great idea and chances are
the problem that you're facing right now
there's an answer
10 minutes away from you from a YouTube
video that's that's online from a book
from a podcast from an interview there's
an answer out there for you and if you
just default to say and I'm going to
model success I'm going to find the
people who've done this and exactly how
they solve that specific problem that
you're facing right now not how they're
living their life right now but how did
they get over the hurdle that you're
facing when you can dig deep and find
those answers and again the bigger the
person is
the more accessible the content is if
you want to learn about Bill Gates's
early life or Steve Jobs's early life or
Oprah Winfrey's early life or whoever it
is it's accessible it's there you can
find this stuff
and it gives you the hope
that it's possible for you and it gives
you the specific strategies that you can
use to apply to your life right now so
you can search team results
success leaves Clues
whatever problem you've got
go model success My Philosophy on losing
is you either win or you learn you win
you got your goal hey hey
congratulations pat yourself on the back
well you learn you learned how not to do
it again hopefully you've improved and
you've gotten better it's only a loss if
you quit it's only a loss if you never
get back up it's only a loss if you stop
trying
somebody asked me on my Instagram
yesterday I love this business that I'm
doing but it's just not working out what
do I do
and my answer is hey if you still love
it you have to keep going
you have to keep trying you have to keep
getting up you have to keep not just
doing the same thing you've been doing
you have to keep looking exploring
trying new ways you have to have to have
to have to keep going because if you
stop now if you love the thing and you
stop now you will regret that decision
for the rest of your life
how many times have you quit on
something that you loved and then you
look back you say I wish I what if I
just kept going what if I just tried one
more day what if I just tried one more
week what if I just kept going because I
would have been in a different spot
and I regret not trying
if you don't love it great quit I mean I
think people stain things for too long
as well people stay in businesses for
too long people saying relationships for
too long out of fear out of insecurity
the love was gone a long time ago and
you should have left a long time ago but
you're too afraid to do it that's not
what I'm talking about I'm talking about
what you love doing and it hasn't worked
out yet you have to keep going
when I was in my first business that
this is the thing that really helped me
I was 19 years old I wanted to quit on
my business I was struggling I was
making no money 300 bucks a month I
owned 30 of a company that was not
making any money and I was working every
day and I just had enough I had enough I
was fed up like how much further can I
go how much longer can I go and just not
see money and not see results and I felt
like I was a pretty happy optimistic
positive guy but it just every day it
just beat me down a little bit more a
little bit more a little bit more and I
was too embarrassed and ashamed to tell
people so it's all by myself and I quit
on my business partner it was the worst
day of my life
and the thing that kept me going
was the fear of regret
that this is not a loss unless I quit
this is not really a loss unless I
actually throw in the towel and go do
something else because I still wanted it
to work in my heart of hearts I still
love this thing I wanted to do something
with it it just I was quitting because I
wasn't getting the results yet
and what I told myself from 19 almost 20
was when when I'm an old man at 40
. you know I'm 40 how old am I now I'm
41 right now so it's funny thinking
about it but when I'm an old man at 40
and my life is over and and I hate my
life and it's it and I'm falling apart
I will regret this I will regret that I
quit
and that feeling
gave me the courage
to go one more day to say I I can't quit
yet this is not I have not given it
everything that I've got I have not left
it all out on the field right there's
still more in me to give to serve the
help there's more effort
but what it did was
forced me to start to think differently
because I couldn't keep going the way I
was going because what I was doing
obviously was not working every idea
that I tried was not working I needed to
think of something radically different
and that's where the idea of modeling
success came in for me it was finally
out of desperation not out of
inspiration not out of mentorship not
anything else not a genius wasn't that
smart it was out of desperation that I
asked myself who else has built a
software company before I cannot be the
first guy to have tried to do this
there's no way somebody has figured this
out like who's done this
and by modeling Bill Gates and how he
started Microsoft that started the path
for my company to start to have success
in a short amount of time I closed my
first deal it was 13 and a half thousand
dollars I felt like I was rich on top of
the world and it gave me momentum it
gave me hope and it also gave me a
strategy that I could keep using
so if you have lost recently
there's two key ways that you need to
get out of it
okay the first is emotional
and then the second is strategy logical
the emotional part is you feel hurt you
feel
scared you feel hopeless you feel
insecure you feel like it it this will
never work it may never work all these
people may be relying on you hopefully
nobody saw you fail we're just afraid of
this judgment and disappointing people
feel like you're not valuable
feel like you're wasting your time
and so the way to get through the
emotional pain
is one to focus on regret that if you
love this thing
and you quit now you will regret this
whether it's 10 years in the future 20
years in the future 30s in the future
you don't want to think back like I had
that shot back then I had that shot and
I didn't take it and I quit too soon
like don't let that be you
fear of regret and the second is service
that you're not doing this just for you
that there's people who are struggling
and they need your help they need your
support there's people who will be
counted on you that your story can
Inspire other people as well
and so sometimes you need the the hug
which is service and sometimes you need
to push which is regret
depending on where you're at what you're
feeling but when you lose
there are lots of logical strategic
practical ways to get out but if you
don't solve the emotional issue first
you'll stay stuck
so it's the emotional issue you have to
deal with first
that just because you lost doesn't mean
that you are a loser as a human right
just because your business hasn't worked
out yet doesn't mean that you as a
person have no self-worth your business
might not have any worth yet but it
doesn't mean that you have no worth and
that's that's something that took me a
long time to be able to separate out
that you are not your business
you are amazing you are gifted you are
talented you are loved you want to
contribute you want to serve and then
you bring that to your business not that
you are your business
once you solve the the emotional side
then you can work to the Practical side
then you can think about okay how do I
how do I solve this problem how do I
break out of this rut that I'm facing
and one of my favorite ways now is
modeling success right find the person
who's done the thing that's why I make
so many videos that's why I profile so
many different entrepreneurs and
athletes and coaches and experts because
maybe the way Oprah Winfrey says it or
Tim Grover says it or Steve Jobs says it
or whoever maybe the way they say it
finally starts to land finally starts to
seep in to give you the idea that you
need to then explode your business
forward
you first start with the emotional side
and solve that
that you are here to serve you are
valuable and that you will regret
quitting on this thing if you quit too
soon and then you can move the tactics
and strategies just like I did with my
business
I quit I quit on my partner
and said I'm done I need to feel
valuable as a human
and realize the next day I leaned in
more on the regret I do not want to live
with regret and being old men at 40 and
look back and say this was my moment
and then that led to the strategy the
Practical side to say okay but I can't
keep going how I'm going how do I solve
this problem okay modeling success
it's only a loss if you quit
it's only a loss if you stay down
it's only a loss if you tell yourself
that you suck and that will it will
never work out
you either win or you learn
the choice is yours
the get back up to learn the lessons
that you learned and to take another
shot because your goals matter because
your dreams matter because the thing
you've got inside your heart right here
can have a huge impact on the world and
we need to get the message out when you
figure out what you stand for everything
becomes so much easier
I meet a lot of entrepreneurs who
they're doing this and they're doing
that and they're doing this and then
also this thing and it's
feels like it's all over the place right
have you ever felt that you're doing so
many things and it feels like it's all
over the place and you don't know how to
bring it together it doesn't feel like
it fits together nobody understands what
you're doing either
the way to bring it together
is to figure out your most important
core value
if you actually did the exercise and
I've talked about this in in both my
books built to serve your one word
if you actually did the exercise you
think about what do I stand for if you
have to pick something right now your
single most important core value what
would you pick mine is belief what's
yours it has all sorts of exercise we
get into and how to actually do it if
you're struggling with that but just
pick pick something it's not going to be
so far off whatever comes to mind right
now pick that
now look at everything that you're
creating that you're selling that you're
offering that's in your mind
and they all now kind of make sense
everything that I do
is belief whether it's making videos
like this whether it's
uh making my nft projects with this
going on my Discord whether it's my
other social media content strategies
whether it's speaking whether it's books
whether it's my entrepreneur Heroes
trading cards that we turned
entrepreneurs into into Heroes and make
them made them their own baseball cards
and use that to raise six figures for
Kiva to help entrepreneurs in Africa
build their businesses right whatever
I'm doing it feels like it could be all
over the place but it's not because it's
still belief because at the end of the
day what I want to do is spread belief
Jeff Bezos wants to spread customer
obsession
he wants to he wants to make a better
experience for customers and so he's in
all sorts of different fields
why it feels like it's all over the
place it's not because Amazon is not
just a book business
Amazon is in the customer experience
business
that's his most important core value
what's your most important core value
it'll help make everything make more
sense it'll help make your life make
more sense your business makes more
sense and it'll help your customers
understand better what you're doing I
remember watching a clip of Jay-Z being
interviewed and
they were asking him how do you move
from
making music to being an entrepreneur to
having all these businesses how does
that make sense
and he said it's just an extension of
being creative
see for him it's not just about the
music it's about expressing creativity
and every field can add more creativity
entrepreneurship can be more creative
investing can be more creative product
lines can be more creative he sees
himself not as a musician but as a force
of creativity his most important core
value is creativity
so it just makes sense to him to be able
to jump from one field to another to
another to another where most people are
stuck in the craft
right you don't just do one thing you
don't want to do one thing that's why
you're an entrepreneur you don't want to
just do one little narrow thing for the
rest of your life
but it feels like you're all over the
place
and you are
until you can wrap it under your most
important core value and what that does
is gives you permission to explore and
to try and to Taste and to go into new
fields
but also
the ability to do something much bigger
because whatever your most important
core value is that's what you want to
spread to the world
I want to spread more belief to the
world Jay-Z wants to spread more
creativity to the world and he could
have done what most people do
most rappers most musicians stick to
just doing that thing okay well that's
what I love and that's what I know and
so I'm just gonna stick to doing that
how you become Mogul status
right how you start to change the rules
of the game how you start to have a much
wider impact and bigger reach is to
recognize that I don't just do one thing
I don't just have one skill
I've got a message
I've got a core value I want to put out
to the world
and there's multiple ways for me able to
do that
so Jay-Z sees himself through the lens
of creativity and then it makes sense
and it gives himself the permission to
go off and Chase those other ambitions
so for you think about what is that most
important core value and some easy hacks
again both my books go through this in a
lot more detail but think about who your
favorite teacher was growing up think
about who what you loved about your
parents think about your favorite movies
your favorite songs uh think about
anything that made you come alive any
experience why did you love that teacher
for me was my my OAC my grade 12 uh
French teacher why it's not because she
taught me French
your favorite teacher wasn't because
they taught your subject matter because
they made you a better human Madame Farr
at my school she helped me believe in
myself more
when I doubted myself when I wasn't
getting the grades that I wanted to get
she helped turn me from a BNC student to
a straight A Plus student in my last
year
she believed in me and she taught me how
to believe in myself that's why I love
her not because she taught me French
right who was your favorite teacher why
why they made you a better human somehow
what was it about them and when you can
connect the dots and all the things that
make you come alive from your favorite
teacher and favorite books and favorite
music favorite lyrics favorite favorite
TV shows favorite movies favorite
friends right favorite Heroes you can
connect the dots you like them but
instead of it it being a happenstance
like you hope that good things happen to
you you can now design it you can
engineer it
I want to bring more believe into my
life and now that that's on my
Consciousness now that I'm aware of it I
can make that happen as opposed to just
hoping something positive happens to me
when you figure out your one word your
most important core value you can
engineer your life to bring more of that
into you and then the more you have you
can give more you can serve more you can
help more you can uplift up others more
you can motivate and Inspire and give
courage and Hope
to the world more
because you have more to give right
review if you're running on empty you
don't have much to give to anybody
so it starts with that awareness
of what is your single most important
core value
and then bring that to your life
and your business
I believe Bezos is about customer
experience
Jay-Z is about creativity what are you
what are you
what do you value the most
and then with that lens look at your
life
look at your business and see where are
you following through
and crushing it and where are you not
living up to it where are you doing the
wrong things
whatever your life needs a little bit
more of that
because when you can look at your life
through that lens that's your best self
looking back at you
that's the life you want to be living
your highest self looking back at you
and saying hey right here
the reason why you're not happy
it's because you're not living your most
important core value
figure that out and you have a road map
you have a guide you have a compass
for the rest of your life you have no
idea what you're capable of you have no
idea you have no idea the person you
could be the things you could accomplish
the things you can do the people you can
serve you have no idea that's why I
don't like 10 year goals 10-year goals
think about who you used to be 10 years
ago you know could that person
accurately with any with any degree of
certainty predict where you could be
right now now like if you're growing and
you're learning you're improving and
you're expanding
you're invested in yourself there's no
way that you know where you're going to
be in one year let alone five years or
ten years you have no idea what you're
capable of and so it comes down to
questioning everything
the question what you can and can't do
you know we're told the story growing up
of what you should do and we're told
everything right you're told when to
show up and where to go and what to wear
and what to eat and what at what age you
should get married and what kind of
career you should go into right we're
told we should do all these things
you're told you're like who you know
nobody ever thought to ask us what we
want for our lives and you may not even
know and that's okay like you may know
where you want to go next but you may
not ultimately know the Final
Destination it's awesome
you know I think if you know the Final
Destination you're thinking small apart
from having a mission you know the
mission the purpose why do you do what
you do I want to solve the world's
biggest problem people don't believe in
themselves enough that's what I'm
chasing down every day
do I know where I'm going to be in in a
year nope am I still making videos
probably but who knows like question
everything I wanna I want people to
believe in themselves more what's the
best way to do that right now it's
through YouTube
but I think a lot of times people have
too certain of a plan and then they end
up
plain small because there's nothing
wrong with having goals and planes but
sometimes you need to jump off that if
you have a 10-year goal quite often you
need to jump off that goal two years in
because something better has come along
that actually better serves who you are
right now because the goal you set was
for who you used to be
you know if you felt that and so I'm
here at genius Network and this group of
super successful entrepreneurs that
meets once a month in masterminds and
talk about their business and pay a lot
of money to be a part of something like
this and every time I'm around people
who are who are having a high degree of
success
I always try to have them pick me apart
so when we when we do there's an
exercise called hot seats where you go
around the table and you basically share
what your biggest
what you think your biggest problem is
and whenever it gets to my turn I just
want people to ask me questions
because
your biggest problem is you don't know
what your biggest problem is
right your biggest problem is you don't
know what your biggest problem is if you
know what your biggest problem was you
can go and solve it
for for entrepreneurs for ambitious
people for you've got goals like
you don't know what the real problem is
the problem you think you have is a
problem you know the problem you think
you have yes very much is a problem but
there's a deeper problem underneath it
that you're missing
that I'm missing so this is where
question everything becomes important my
default has become instead of pretending
like I know everything and I know all my
problems that I don't know anything and
ask me questions and in the process of
asking me questions and learning about
me maybe you come up with some insight
that I've never seen before
everybody has their own way of
processing
given advice you know so I'm around
people here everybody here has a seven
or eight figure nine figure business and
people here have sold their businesses
for nine figures crazy
awesome
and so they have their own way of
processing things and asking questions
and breaking somebody down
so instead of me coming in with
the question and having them trying to
fit into my box I'd rather fit into
theirs because in trying to understand
how they process things
it'll probably make me stretch and grow
and learn
and I'm probably going to get a better
result because they're going to see
something that I don't see
and so
in the process of questioning everything
when people can break you down and
you're open to it right because we're we
hold on to our identity like no no
that's not going to work for me you know
even boom got a B
I am allergic to bees
maybe I should question that I don't
feel like questioning that today though
do not want to get stung by a bee I once
got stung by a bee and uh
only time in my life I've been sung by a
bee and it I was on the floor and my my
back just swelled up from the bee sting
um
anyway
maybe question everything except bee
stings how about that there's been times
when people giving me advice and it made
sense and it really fit and sometimes
when it didn't
and and even if it doesn't make sense
what I'll default in my head the same is
this is either nothing like the person
didn't read me correctly or it's the
whole thing
think about if you're really opposed to
somebody's advice or feedback for you if
somebody gives you great advice like oh
wow that's really cool I should go and
do that cool they they met you where
you're at and you understand it
but there'll be other times when it it
doesn't feel right
and it could be that it just wasn't a
fit and they're giving you the wrong
advice or
you're so blind and this is what gets me
excited is maybe I'm so blind maybe I
believe my story so much that the thing
that you're talking about is actually
the whole thing like it's all I should
care about because figuring out how to
solve that because I'm so tied to my own
story that I'm not questioning enough
and coming back to the B Spot hopefully
it's gone I'm not questioning enough
and figuring that out becomes the the
whole unlock so a quick story on this I
did a life coaching session with
garyvee's lead coach Beth hendel and at
first I was shocked I didn't know I
didn't know garyvee had a life coach so
it was very excited to talk to her and
just like I've been explaining this
video I went through her process like
like how do you ask questions what do
you want to know about me I don't want
it to be if this is a coaching session
just treat me as a shoot me as a client
treat me as somebody who's going to
coach what do you need to know from my
story and how I act and I'm gonna I'm
gonna be as open as honest as possible
and what it led to was
a lot of the stuff she was saying
um was great but my single biggest
insight and takeaway was this and I'm
practicing this every single day now
the one takeaway that has honestly
changed my life
historically I've been the person who
believes in the plan
so what's my plan to get to the next
step like I want to go here what's my
plan what's my plan what's my plan so I
have the belief in the plan
and I wake up every day and I just do
the plan because I believe in the plan
I'll have some days where I don't
believe in a plan anymore like will this
plan help get me anywhere is this plan
still working like it's not working
anymore and that leads to some anxiety
for me because I believe in the plan and
when the plan doesn't work what happens
and so what I end up doing is making a
new plan
so I have a plan I believe in a plan
until I don't believe in it anymore
causes anxiety come up with a new plan
the following so when creating a new
plan then I have certainty in the plan
again and I'm fine and I'm rock and
rolling but there are some days
there are some days when I can't come up
with a new plan the plan I have I don't
believe in anymore and I'm racking my
brain to come up with a new plan and I
can't come up with a new plan
if I'm the kind of person who believes
in the plane and then I can't come up
with a new plan that's a really uh
stress-inducing anxiety-filled place to
be and it doesn't happen that often
but when it does and I can't come up
with a new plan especially in the moment
while what I would end up telling myself
is great things happen to me you know
what you know what happened great things
happen to you
and I would use it as a self-soothing
mechanism as a coping mechanism
because I didn't want to just stay
locked because locked in that stress and
and it would be downward spiral
like if I believe in the plan and the
plan is not working and I can't come
with a new plan then I don't know what
to do with my life and that would create
a downward spiral I've never gone
anywhere close to depression or suicide
but that would lead to some dark that
could lead to some dark places and so
the way that I come out of it is just
say great things will happen to me great
things happen to me they already they
always happen to me great things happen
to me and I'll figure this out and that
gives me the Comfort to
move forward into the uncertainty and
then something will come that I will
solve it and what she said was garyvee's
life coach was
what you say to yourself
when you need that
self-soothing of great things happen to
you
needs to be your default state
so instead of believing in the plan as
your default State and only going to
great things happen to you when you are
at the lowest of your low
flip it to the point where great things
happen to you is the default
because that's where you're actually
your best self and I really felt that I
don't know how to do it
but even in questioning how do I do it
I just have to believe the great things
happen to me so a big part of my routine
now is is I don't know how many times
I'll I'll say that to myself feel that
great things happen to me I'm going to
put it as my new cell phone background
it's a it's a constant reminder even
making this video is another
reinforcement of it when people ask me
what my goals are there's been these
exercises we've been doing in genius
Network here and uh I just I just keep
reminding myself I don't know I don't
have a 10 year goal great things happen
to me
it's a constant reminder and I
I would I used to live it before this
awareness
I don't know like how many times would I
feel really down and low in anxiety
filled that I couldn't come with a new
plan
maybe half of one percent of the time
like really small amounts and now I'm
probably living in great things happen
to me maybe
five percent of the time ten percent of
the time which is a huge jump from half
of one percent but it's still not my
default mode yet I'm still believing the
planned guy that's my ongoing challenge
to myself that's how I'm questioning
it's the willingness to question what
you're doing because what you're doing
right now has gotten you to where you're
at and if you're if you're happy with
where you're at cool but if you want
more you want to create more you want to
serve more you want to bring more you
want to help more you want more
you want to change and you have to
change and the change starts with not
just questioning everything out there
question everything in here
questioning what you believe to be true
question who you think you are
questioning for sure what you think
you're capable of
because when you can get to the root of
that amazing things can happen great
ideas flow through you teach yourself to
learn to understand to feel that great
ideas flow through you that when you are
feeling bold powerful courageous
ambitious and idea comes to you that is
the right perfect idea for you right now
and don't let your head talk you down
from doing it I think most of us live
small I think I think we're constantly
living small we're so concerned about
our friends telling us that our ideas
suck it's us
it's ourselves it's you telling yourself
that your idea sucks that you can never
do that we feel great one day this is
the entrepreneur roller coaster right
you feel great one day oh my God this is
such a great idea I could go do this
this is amazing and maybe you start
taking some action on it but then what
immediately happens is your head starts
taking over so well you I mean you can't
do that because you you don't have the
school the education the parents the
connections you live in the wrong
country you're the wrong gender race Etc
and then and then it stops
meanwhile dummies are winning off of
your idea with less heart with less
drive with less ambition with less of a
desire to do good they're winning off of
your idea because they went off and did
something while you are stuck
overthinking your idea this is what we
do this is what entrepreneurs especially
the the heart
centered ones do
stock constantly over analyzing
overthinking and stuck in the mud
instead of actually creating and the way
to go through it is to trust in your
ideas
if you're concerned that that's too
egotistical like oh I'm so great I got
these great ideas great take yourself
out of the equation
trust that the idea came from somewhere
and it was given to you and it's your
responsibility to birth it into life
it's not even your idea it was given to
you
and then go off and create
one of the things that has really helped
me achieve speed and momentum is
I've learned to not judge the ideas that
come to me
I've just said you know what because I
came up with this idea now I have to go
do something about it and sometimes it
turns into the next great thing and
sometimes it goes nowhere that's okay
right the first top 10 video I ever made
on my channel was on Kanye West and he's
behind me on the wall there he is Kanye
West
because my friend
made a blog post about Kanye that was in
a negative light and so I wanted to make
it positive say Hey you can learn from
him and so I made a top 10 video on
Kanye West just to show my friend I had
other things planned today shut that all
down just to make this one video just to
show my friend with no plan of this is
going to be my next big idea right
people say well how did you know I
didn't know I got an idea and I did
something about it
I'm not that smart to be able to project
10 years forward and say Here's Where
the world is going right maybe I can
leave that to Elon Musk I'm not that
smart
but it came to me so I did it and it
turned into something amazing
I've had other ideas that that I started
and didn't go anywhere either the idea
wasn't good enough or or more likely my
energy just kind of faded from it and so
I stopped doing it but at least I gave
it a shot all of these ideas that you've
got you don't know which one's going to
work out they could all be practically
speaking great ideas what's the best
idea for you I don't know you don't know
either until you start to try it
by taking the immediate action on it
you have to trust in your ideas that
they came to you for a reason are you
supposed to do something about them
so how do we start doing how do you
start taking the action how do you start
getting getting St unstuck in your head
of all the stuff that holds us back from
actually creating let me give you some
Steps step number one
idea to action
take your brain out of the equation
there's a phrase that when when you're
in your head you're dead like as soon as
you start overthinking something it's
over
you came up with the idea you're gonna
do something about it when today
you came with the idea so you're gonna
do something about it when right now
what's your next idea what are you
thinking of right to go do something
about it immediate action take the
because you came up with the idea
therefore you must go do the thing
that's the training you want to give
yourself doesn't mean you have to go and
do some big thing but you have to get
started immediate momentum you want to
start a YouTube channel great you pull
out your phone and you make a video it
doesn't matter what you say it doesn't
matter what the lighting is don't worry
about the sound don't worry about having
a fancy microphone or fancy camera you
pull out your phone you press record and
you say you're starting the channel and
you post that first video
okay but then it's gonna suck great
which Lisa Point number two expect to
suck at the beginning
why do you expect to be great out of the
gate you will not be great out of the
gate doesn't mean that you suck as a
human just means that your product sucks
but it's your first attempt that's okay
when you try anything you fall when you
get on a bicycle you didn't just ride
right you get a skateboard you didn't
just go
you're gonna suck that's okay that's the
learning process you're gonna learn a
lot more and get better a lot quicker by
actually trying where we're stuck in
learning and researching and planning
and then nothing that ends up getting
created you are wasting your best energy
on planning this is what most this is
what most people do this is what happens
almost all the time you come with an
idea you think it's a great idea
oh my gosh it's such a great idea great
you spend the next day or until you go
to sleep planning researching preparing
and then you wake up tomorrow and say I
can't do that that's crazy that idea I
had yesterday is crazy I can't do that
who did I think I was to be able to do
that you spent your best energy your
most confident energy your most bold
energy on doing the wrong thing planning
instead of making planning is important
but it's not the first thing you should
do the first thing you do is take some
kind of action some kind of immediate
momentum some kind of commitment
especially to somebody else that you're
going to do something
so if you want to start a YouTube
channel you take out your phone and say
hi I'm going to start my YouTube channel
I don't know I'm gonna make content of
I'm really nervous but I've been putting
this off for five years and I'm tired of
putting things off so I don't know join
my journey and let's see how it goes
great post
and as you start making
you're gonna get better at it your first
thing is supposed to suck if you're
going to get started you're going to
start making YouTube videos as an
example and your first video is amazing
then you actually suck then you waited
too long your first version of whatever
you do should be terrible that's okay
so Step One is listen to the ideas trust
the ideas they are right for you because
they came to you you got to do something
about it take immediate action
and set number two is expect to suck
reduce the burden of expectation on
yourself that you have to be great from
the start as kids we do this right we
start we try we fail we laugh and as
adults all of a sudden we're afraid to
do anything
and what you do is just slide into more
of your comfort zone and more your
comfort zone more of your comfort zone
more of your comfort zone and then
realize why do I hate my life so much
because you're doing the same thing
every day because you're afraid to
Branch out a little bit
expect to suck
reduce that burden that you have to be
amazing
and if you keep practicing you keep
loving it you keep building it guess
what you're gonna get great at it
doesn't have to take a decade this hacks
his shortcuts model success you'll get
there faster
but you still have to do the journey and
step one of the journey is the most
important step and is also the most
painful step that it's gonna suck
amazing every time you suck at something
at the start pat yourself on the back
you did a good job
step number three
and this is just the caveat is pay
attention to your energy when you come
up with ideas okay I'm assuming you're
in a positive bold ambitious confident
courageous State when you are feeling a
positive emotion the ideas that flow
through you are the right ideas for you
however when you're feeling negative low
you're feeling judgmental you're feeling
anger you're feeling depression you're
feeling rage you're you're upset that
somebody else is having success when
you're in a negative mindset
the ideas that come to you are not the
one ones for you those are the ones to
sit on right like I'm gonna show her I'm
gonna I'm gonna do this thing to him I'm
gonna I'm gonna get my Revenge by doing
that okay let those are the ideas to sit
on and it's funny because those are the
ideas we usually act on
the spontaneous ideas that come to you
that are negative you're more likely to
act on than the spontaneous ones that
come to you that are positive
you're more likely to send that nasty
text or leave that negative review or do
that negative thing instead of the
positive one and so if you're in a
negative state of mind that's when it's
worth waiting till tomorrow you know if
tomorrow you think it's the right call
okay then then let's think about it but
not in the moment don't do the negative
ones in the moment
but if it's positive if you just came
back from a seminar or you're watching
this video or you're around amazing
humans and you get these great ideas
those are the ones that you need to take
some immediate action on
you have amazing ideas
who have a a heart and a soul that wants
to serve that wants to help that wants
to contribute that wants to not just
fill your pockets and fill your bank
account but also contribute and help
other people you you know you've got
something much bigger inside you
but it does not come out
unless you start to listen to those
ideas and start to do something about
them
so the next time an idea comes to you
maybe you got one right now maybe
something's flowing through you right
now
learn to trust that idea
tell yourself that great ideas flow
through you
that you need to take some immediate
action on it and that it's gonna suck at
the beginning and that's the best and
that's how you learn
because if you kept doing that do that
for three months do that for six months
do that for 12 months
the amount of amazing things you're
going to help create for yourself for
your family for your community for the
world
is going to be just outstanding and I
can't wait to see what you end up making
as an introvert Making Connections
always seemed incredibly scary to me I
hate going to networking events I'm not
the life of a party I don't know uh how
to approach people and ask them
questions and it always just felt I
think at the end of the day very fake
and inauthentic and just not me you know
I don't know how to introduce myself and
I don't know I don't know what to talk
about I want to sit here and talk I'm
here in Arizona and it's beautiful and
it's sunny and it's amazing but I don't
I don't I don't want to just talk about
the weather you know I don't want to
talk about
boring
superficial stuff and
it took me a long time to get
comfortable coming to events and I'm
this is actually a great moment because
I'm here at genius Network it's a I just
came out of a two-day event where people
are paying 25 000 to be a part of and
the next two days uh it's another event
where they're paying a hundred thousand
dollars to be part of and I'm a guest
here speaking at um at both events and I
would have I would have never like
younger Evan would have never come to
something like this because
not that it's not valuable just I would
have been too afraid to to network and
to uh to ask for help and to introduce
myself and all of those things what I've
discovered if you're an introvert
what I've discovered is that introverts
are great listeners
and we care
and you can be a fantastic networker if
you're an introvert but your goal is not
to know the entire room and the goal is
not to run into the the event and say
look at me here's what I do and where
the shiniest suit and be be the
loudmouth if that's you awesome roll
with it but if it's not your goal is to
just connect with a few people on a
really meaningful level
I've connected over the past couple days
with some amazing people who've given me
some amazing advice and connections and
experiences and
just amazing people but it hasn't been I
don't there's lots of people who I
haven't connected with
you know there were maybe
50 people here over the past two days
and in the bigger the more expensive
group I think there's 30 people or 20
people coming and I probably won't get
to talk to everybody
um probably not I mean maybe
but I'm not I'm not I'm not judging
myself for not knowing everybody I'm not
judging myself for
how many business cards I leave with
though I don't the people you still use
business cards I don't have any business
cards I'm not judging myself if I
connected with them or not it's more I'd
rather spend
time with a few people
who I can connect with on some kind of
level and
that ends up leading to so much better
things Joe polich is the guy who runs
this so this is his office and he's the
one puts his events together and he's
he's known as the most connected man in
the world right some of his bios and
websites will say people talk about him
he's the most connected man in the world
in hanging around him
for the past few days I can understand
why so if we're going to reverse
engineer
Joe polish's success and he'll he'll say
that he's you know on the introverted
side
um
he's invited me to his home
he's I came in a couple days early and
helped him with his team and His Channel
and he invited me to stay at his home
today is our day off in between the two
events and he's invited me to go work
out with him and go do some IVs with
vitamins in it and go sit in a hot sauna
then jump in a nice cold bath and ask me
how I'm doing and what I'm up to and if
I need if I need anything or if I want
to use his office I mean I'm using I'm
using his office I guess the outside the
film today it's too beautiful today not
to film outside but but whatever I need
he doesn't just do that for anybody you
know he's not just going to open up his
home for anybody
and he's really trying to spend time
think about me if I would do that I'm
thinking man probably not and so that's
that's maybe a learning for me because
I've run events I've hosted my own
events and they usually just knock me
out when I when I posted my thought
Leadership Academy in Toronto it would
knock me out I mean the last day of one
of the um
the last day of my event I remember I I
passed out like I had a break of 15
minutes and I I passed out and fell
asleep on a floor like on my dance floor
because I was giving so much and then my
my body gave out on me
and so I couldn't imagine then also like
Joe's got such a crazy week think about
how much people are paying him right
they pay him twenty five thousand
dollars for
the event that just finished and then a
hundred thousand dollars for the event
that's coming up
you gotta deliver some value right if
people are coming and they're paying a
hundred thousand dollars to be here that
that's
gotta be at least for me incredibly
stressful to do that and while he's in
the middle of all of that he's worried
about me and how I'm doing and if I want
to stay with him and if I need to if I
want to go do some vitamin IVs and if
I'm being looked after if I need an
internet connection or a place to work
and the amount of text that he sent
while he's
in the sauna or working out or
doing his meetings
I was like how are you still thinking
about me you've got you've got so much
going on I I don't I mean it's something
that that I'm honestly inspired by and I
find aspirational
but he does it so well
and it's like he can't do that for
everybody and so uh you know I'm
grateful to Guess that he saw something
in me that he'd want to spend that kind
of time with
but he's very selective over who he
brings in and then once you're in he's
he's
going to be the greatest resource of all
time
and I think that's how you win
ultimately at least for me I think it's
a fantastic model for me to learn from
and keep trying to do better at and that
how can you win as an introvert when you
are networking
and trying to help people
introverts are great listeners
introverts care we want to help we want
to serve and we can't do it for
everybody because we let too many people
in we then we have no energy for
ourselves
and recognize that that's how you you
that's your secret superpower
that's your superpower
your superpower my superpower is to find
just a few people
at every place you go to your goal is
not to meet the whole event it's made a
few people
and figure out how you can help them and
genuinely help them like generally serve
them not not just if I help them do this
and they're going to help me do that
right we're not don't don't approach it
as a transaction I think introverts are
great at this right it's not on
transaction you we value relationships
but are too afraid to go up and say hi
to people and don't like the The Fluffy
talk
so just make it a goal to find a few
people
and be of service and great things
happen one of the things I've taken away
and just reinforced from the past couple
days is great things happen to me
and I'm I'm actually becoming less of a
goal person like where do you want to be
next year I have no idea because great
things happen to me
because if you keep pouring into other
people and keep bringing value and keep
helping
great things will happen to you that you
you never thought of
you know that you never thought would
exist and yet here they are now showing
up in your life
and so a challenge for you would be to
think about
whether it's the next event you're going
to or even just some people in your
network
like who do you already know
who are good people
being the business of collecting good
people like who do you already know
who's a good person who you
you want to serve and help on a deeper
level
and just find a way to reach out and
help them
be of service
I make a list of of the top kind of 100
people that I want to stay in touch with
because I'll forget I'll forget to stay
in touch I'm too present-minded Focus
but if I haven't stayed in touch with
them in the past 90 days I'll find some
some way to help whether it's
sharing something on social whether it's
making a video giving them some YouTube
advice to just connecting asking how it
can be a resource
I schedule in the ongoing connection
because
these people have helped me a lot and I
want to continue to help them and if
you're just going strategy you know
continue to help successful people will
lead to you having more success because
it will they will find ways to come back
and help you you're almost guilting them
to do it even better is to not even be
as strategic about it just by putting
out good energy just by serving others
just by using that good karma it comes
and in the process of giving if you can
remind yourself the great things happen
to you
that if I just keep showing up and
serving and helping and doing my very
best every day
great things will happen to me great
things will happen to you great things
will happen to you you just have to keep
going you are what you consistently do
it's not what you do some of the times
it's not what you do when you feel
motivated or you had enough sleep or
that it's the perfect conditions out
there you are where you consistently do
the one-off moments don't mean anything
you can have a chocolate bar but if the
rest of your days are eaten healthy all
the time guess what you're not going to
gain a ton of weight and likewise the
other way around if you have a life that
you're not following through on any of
your goals and then you have one great
moment or one great day guess what you
fall back down
this is where a lot of entrepreneurs
struggle because you have these moments
where you feel alive empowered on top of
the world amazing and you might even put
a little bit of that into practice but
if it's not consistent
then it never happens and it's almost
better to not even know what you're
capable of this is the part of the curse
of being an entrepreneur is you know
you're capable of great things you see
an amazing future amazing world of what
you could build
but then you also see your lack of
follow-through and the lack of delivery
and the lack of execution and it's that
constant grind against your self-worth
to say I should be doing more but I'm
not it's almost better to have no goals
and have no dreams and I have no
ambition because then you're good then
you're in in Bliss because you're
ignorant of what's what you're capable
of
so how do you fix it I look at myself
and anytime I want to make a change in
my life it goes to the schedule
my schedule has to map to my ambitions
right your schedule needs to map to your
missions what you say you wanted a life
needs to be in your life right hope is
not is not enough hoping that you have
enough inspiration hoping that you get
motivated hoping that you'll be ready
one day that's not enough it's not a day
of the week right someday is not it's
not a day of the week Sunday is but
someday is not a day of the week and so
whatever you wanted a life has to be in
your calendar
whatever success looks like for you how
finances relationships whatever it looks
like for you whatever that perfect
vision is in your head whatever you have
on your dream board of what you want to
accomplish in your life okay great how
do you accomplish that how do you get
there it's your habits success is habits
success equals habits
wear your habits in your calendar
so what are you doing
when you wake up in the morning what are
you doing every single day of the week
what are you doing for planning for your
for the you know the the quarter and the
week and the even the year ahead what
are you doing what are you doing to
change what's in your calendar to make
sure that if you actually did those
things like if you look at your week
look at your next week
look at what's in your calendar
your health goals your your relationship
goals not just the goals but the
execution against it you can say you
want to have a great body or you want to
get healthy this year great what does
that look like where in your calendar
are you spending time planning your food
and working out and taking care of
yourself it has to be a time not just
not just a blank space this is the
problem we'll book a lot of our business
stuff but not our personal stuff I book
all my personal stuff my time with Nina
is in my calendar the time to celebrate
with the kids and families in the
calendar it's in the calendar it's as
important as a business meeting because
what happens is when you have blank
spots in your calendar
you start living in unintentional life
right when you set up a calendar and you
create the blocks of time for where
you're going to spend when you're going
to wake up and what you're going to work
on and when you're going to take care of
your body and when you're going to take
care of your relationships or take care
of South
right if when that's in your calendar
that's living an intentional life
when you just have a bunch of blank
spots
you get distracted pull out your phone
and dive into Instagram and three hours
later you're still on it and you feel
worse about yourself so it's about
creating an intentional life for
yourself and that starts with your
calendar you are what you consistently
do you are what you repeatedly do so how
do we do it how are some of the steps
what what are the three action items for
you well step one is to figure out what
do you want
especially on a belief scale like what
do you want to believe
what is the difference between where you
are now and where you want to go and
this can be hard for Achievers because
you probably
are the most ambitious person that you
know right you're the one who's caring
about other people you're the one
encouraging on the people but nobody's
doing it for you so what are the beliefs
that you need to have what's the most
important belief change that you need to
have that you're not getting from your
immediate circle doesn't mean you stop
pointing that the people keep doing it
it's amazing you're built to serve it's
going to fill you up but you need
something to pour into you otherwise you
don't grow
right if you're just feeding other
people and nothing's feeding you you
don't grow you're just gonna get drained
so what's going to be feeding into you
the belief that would make the
difference between where you are right
now and where you want to be what is
that single belief great so getting
clear on what that one don't don't worry
about having a hundred different beliefs
yet tackle one thing at a time what's
the single most important belief that
you need to have for yourself to get
your next level of growth great step
number two
who is doing that right now
who was doing that and creating an
environment and habits around it so for
me I want to believe in myself more I
want to spread more belief to other
people as well so what's in my
environment well my physical environment
you can see here from me wearing this
outfit to having you know the pictures
behind me on the wall these people all
inspire me for different reasons to the
videos that I make and consume to the
work that I do in my community to the
new Discord that I set up Evan
carmichael.biz if you want to come and
join us uh that's part of what I do
every day to make me feel like I believe
in myself more believe in in me as a
human believe in the work that I'm doing
believe that it will work out I want
more belief and I've designed habits and
rituals to help me get it where most
people again do not wake up and feel
like today is going to be an amazing day
and they're just bursting full of energy
and on top of the world from the moment
they wake up no I woke up this morning
it was just past seven
um I don't sleep to an alarm so I woke
up and just I wake up when my body tells
me to wake up so I woke up just past
seven
um I didn't know what day it was you
know I'm tired I wake up I go to the
bathroom and on my way I put on an oldie
song and and all these music gets me
moving gets me bouncing gets me jiving
and then immediately start going to
community stuff right I'm in the
bathroom I'm listening to my oldies I
look at my intention for the day today
I'm recording YouTube videos how do I
want to show up what I want to do who do
I want to be showing up on the content
and then go to community
and I go I joined my Discord and I'm
giving love to people because it makes
me feel like what I do matters and it
makes me feel more belief right I've got
videos on that you know remind me of who
I want to be I'm around my heroes and
mentors but deciding
the difference that you need to believe
between now and where you're going and
then two putting it into your calendar
especially the morning routine of how
you're going to show up so it's not an
accident so that you don't hope that
that you show up and you do it today but
that it's it's marked in your calendar
and in step three and this is the
hardest for a lot of people is you do
what's in your calendar here's a really
important rule that if you do this it
will change your life
when you are deciding
what to do in your calendar on the day
of
you cannot change what's in today's
calendar you can change tomorrows but
you can't change today here's what I
mean if you're looking at your calendar
and you set out your goals right here
here's who I want to be this week here's
what I want to get done this week I want
to wake up at this time and I want to
work out and I want to connect with my
family and I want to serve and whatever
whatever the chunks of time are for you
there's a tendency to in the moment
change
where on Sunday you look at your
calendar and said here's what I'm going
to do this is going to be an exciting
week it's great but then come Thursday
morning you don't want to wake up at
that time or you see what's in the
calendar I don't want to go for that run
I don't want to make those calls I don't
want to make those videos and then you
don't and you quickly fall off track
sound familiar is it making sense it
looks so great on the weekend when you
plan this but now when you're actually
doing it you don't do it
and then what happens is the next time
you say you're going to do something you
don't believe yourself because you let
yourself off the hook too easily
so the rule becomes
you can only change tomorrow's calendar
not today you're tired
you had a rough day
you don't think this workout's working
for you anymore you don't think making
videos is aligned with you anymore great
tomorrow you don't have to do it
tomorrow you can change but today you're
doing it because you said you were going
to do it tomorrow you can sleep in
because today you had a last night you
had a rough night so today your ex
retired but you're still getting up when
you said you're going to get up and you
still do the things that are in your
calendar and then tomorrow you can sleep
in and tomorrow you can adjust
the workout the business plan whatever
if it doesn't feel right anymore but not
today don't trust yourself in the moment
because your brain is going to tell you
to play small your brain is going to
remind you why you can't do these things
your brain is going to find a reason for
you to let yourself off the hook again
like it did last time
you know what you want
so what you said you were going to do on
the weekend when you looked at your
calendar
you have to show up the day of
so you have to get really clear on the
belief that you want to have that will
make the difference for you you need to
surround yourself with those Heroes and
role models and change your morning
routine to reflect it and then you need
to actually do what's in your calendar
and if something's off or it doesn't
work you change it for tomorrow but you
can't change it in the moment you are
what you consistently do
you know you've got so much inside you
and so much that you want to share and
serve and help
and you keep letting yourself down
and it's it's time to change it
you're ready to change it
you're ready to move past it you're
ready to be the person who follows
through you're ready to be the person
who with that big dream starts to make
momentum towards it
the only difference is being the person
who does what you consistently say you
will do so I love seeing how people do
their daily routines I love I love
seeing how they start today I love
seeing what their workout routines are
mindset routines are because
hopefully you can pick up one little
tweak one little hack one of the things
that you can try out on your own to be
able to make your life a little bit
better I'm sitting here outside genius
Network we've just been having some
amazing meetings I spent the past two
days in a group where you pay 25 000 a
year to be in and the next two days we
have to pay a hundred thousand dollars a
year to be in and um I'm grateful to be
able to meet so amazing humans who've
built some amazing businesses so this
video leads to a couple of thoughts for
me the first is I think it's great to
have a
healthy balance of ordering chaos most
days you live in order most days you
should have a morning routine most days
you wake up when you do the thing you
say you're going to do most days whether
it's working out or for your business
for your mindset feeding information
into you I go on my believe walks every
morning some of the things I do right
somebody asked me yesterday how do you
say so positive well I go on a belief
walk every morning I go outside get some
sign it's nice here in Arizona let me
show you let me show you I'm it's
snowing right now in in it's I'm filming
this uh the end of April and it's
snowing in in Toronto but I'm here
crazy crazy Sun you know super grateful
we got palm trees in the back I'm gonna
get some of the Sun out of my face but
I go for my believe walk pretty much
every morning and I believe walk what
that is is just help me set my mind for
the day what do I want to accomplish
today what what am I doing today I
forget you know I forget what my
responsibilities are and why I'm doing
it because no matter how great a day I
had yesterday
today I wake up and feel like I'm
starting over and so having something in
the morning that helps you remind
yourself of the intention that you've
got for today I think is really valuable
it's really helpful at least it is for
me having music on you know putting
music on that makes you bounce makes you
go up and makes you makes you move
because when you move it transforms your
mind as well when your body's moving
your mind starts moving when your body
is slow and lazy and tired and your mind
is slow and lazy and tired as well and
then feeding my brain with with
knowledge with inspiration with it's why
I make all these videos because I want
to learn from the being Gene I want to
learn from Oprah Winfrey I want to learn
from Elon Musk I want to learn from
people who are thinking just way bigger
than me and so I think
back to the idea of order versus chaos
most days you should wake up and and be
in order most days you should wake up
and do your routine most days you should
wake up and do what you said you were
going to do because these are the things
that you know works for you every now
and then though it's great to inject
some chaos because entrepreneurs we love
chaos and it's great to challenge the
order and it's great to see is this
thing that I was doing this is still
serving is it still work for me is it
still something that I want to be doing
and so that's we're going to an event
going to a conference going to meet
other people right so I'm hanging out
with all these successful entrepreneurs
here in Arizona and
and it's great and a lot of it is a
reinforcement of what I'm already doing
is working and you hopefully pick up
some nuggets this is what in a 10-day
trip 11 day trip something like that on
my first two days here they gave us uh
free breakfast at the hotel and so my
wife Nina was here with me and we went
for the breakfast the first two days and
I don't usually eat breakfast I don't
usually eat until at least two o'clock
so uh I'll eat between two and six
o'clock every day
sometimes I sometimes I start at two
sometimes I start at six or somewhere in
between I'm usually done by eight and
that's what I did on a daily basis but
since I was away you know you know what
let's have some breakfast and I wasn't
like junking out on every sweet cereal
and syrup all over the place but I
intently kind of went off my routine
still did my belief walk so the music
um and then after two days like you know
what if I keep doing this for the next
10 days 11 days I'm gonna be uh I'm not
gonna feel right you know and so I'm I'm
right now back on my my routine and the
little bit of chaos every now and then I
think is good
it helps you identify is the things that
I'm doing is it working is it helping me
do I want to keep doing it or not what
what is serving me ongoing and so
sometimes you need to get out of your
your environment to to get that shipped
so going to an event going to a
conference meeting other people being
around more ambitious or equally
ambitious people as you can help you
come back with some new ideas even if
you go on vacation like you ever go on a
vacation you come back I want to do this
this this and this you feel you feel
rejuvenated you feel energetic you feel
alive you feel ready to go off and just
make some big change right because you
change your environment and so
that will force some chaos into you that
can hopefully lead to some positive
results so I think most days you should
live in the order you know here's my
routine and I think it works and I'm
sticking to it and then every now and
then you need to inject a little bit of
chaos into it and hopefully in that
chaos it's something positive that
you're injecting into yourself that
makes you pause makes you reflect it
makes you see is this order that I set
up for myself still lead me to the life
that I want one of the things that I
have taken away from the past two days
of hanging with the 25k a year members
is the importance of tracking and right
now what I've done then is started
tracking
what time I eat every day
and what how many uh push-ups Jumping
Jacks and squats that I'm doing every
day and one of the speakers was talking
about in in general as entrepreneurs
what we're always trying to do is go for
new highs what's our new high break our
break a break a new record right go for
new highs where
a great way to think about it is instead
of always trying to break new highs
because that's
almost impossible to do
just work on your bad days work on
lowering the raising the lows so if
you're thinking about a health goal for
example and you want to you want to hit
a certain weight well you're the average
of what you've done for the past year
right if you if you eat like crap half
the time and eat super healthy half the
time you're gonna get a certain weight
outcome if you eat or fast some days but
then eat super junky other days you'll
get a certain weight outcome so you're
the average of all your highs and lows
and we tend to focus only on the highs
and we don't focus enough on the lows
where if you can just instead of always
focusing on getting better highs just
lowering the impact of the lows then you
can get a better average result which is
what your end result ends up being and
so
you don't know until you track it so if
you're on a health Journey there may be
days you eat super clean awesome and you
can eat cleaner on some days great but
you'll probably get the best results by
those days where you fall off the rails
where you cheat where you make yourself
not so proud where if I'm having
breakfast at the buffet at the hotel on
the bad days you don't let it go too bad
there's a concept of bumpers like in a
bowling alley you have bumpers down the
side and so you don't let it get too bad
and so if you cheat or you eat then
you're not having all like pounds of
syrup and everything else that you
minimize the impact or if you're gonna
if you're gonna work out you're gonna
make your calls you're gonna make some
videos that whatever your worst days are
just making them not as bad
and track so by tracking you can see how
what you're doing and so I started
tracking what time I ate so yes it was
the first day so I ate at 6 15. I didn't
eat anything all day eight at 6 15 at
night and ended up doing I don't know 50
push-ups 100 squats and 200 jumping
jacks something like that and then today
I'll start tracking again and it gives
you a baseline for where you're at and
so that's a new thing that I'm gonna try
and right now my plan is track those
metrics what time I ate how many
push-ups Jumping Jacks and squats that I
do every day those four things that I'm
measuring and track that every day just
on a piece of paper and then on the
weekend transfer that into a Google
sheet and so I have historic data now
here's the thing it's an idea right now
I'm super excited about the idea I'm
away from my environment of injected
chaos into it and I got inspired to do
this so immediate action I'm doing it
right you don't have to wait to go home
to buy a Fitbit to buy a fancy tracker
to XYZ right this is what we tend to do
you get inspired by something and then
you go off and
you plan and plan and plan and when when
I get home or next week or next month or
on my birthday or New Year I'm going to
do it I said just do it just get started
just just immediate imperfect action is
always the answer
and I'm excited by it right now and it
might be that might make a huge
difference to me it might be a big game
changer it might be all like talk about
you know to to give you advice for the
next 10 years of my life or maybe it
Fizzles out you know or maybe I try it
for three days and I leave here in a
couple days and then that's it and I
don't do it again it's still worth the
experiment and that's what chaos brings
the chaos brings new ideas and the
newness is not productive the newness is
creative but the newness is gonna fail a
lot the newness is not going to be
efficient again it won't be productive
and we judge ourselves that every new
idea has to be the perfect idea it's
that's it's the exact opposite
you know like new ideas most of them
will fail it's not that it's a bad idea
it just may not be the right idea for
you at this moment in your life right
now and so I'm trying it but in general
back to the idea of ordering chaos I
think most days you wake up and have a
schedule
I think most States should wake up and
do the thing at least talking to myself
Evan Carmichael Evan most days you
should wake up and have a schedule we'll
see she wake up and do the thing that
you said you were going to do and have
your routine and stick to it because
that has consistently gotten new results
and if you keep doing that you'll keep
getting more results
and every now and then you need to
inject a little bit of chaos into it you
need to be around other people who are
doing big things you need to question
the order and question the structure and
ask yourself does this structure right
now still serve me and is there a better
way
and it's in that combination that I
think you ultimately find your happiness
your success your purpose
and um yeah you get the life that you
want the biggest risk is not taking a
risk at all
I love it so many people are so afraid
to follow their dreams to have this big
idea that they have that they want to go
off and accomplish we have this big
vision for ourselves and we're so afraid
of making the wrong decision that we do
nothing
that you see this big goal and you have
three four five potential paths and you
have limited resources limited time
limited money limited abilities and you
want to say I need to make the perfect
decision because if I make the wrong one
it all falls apart
and as a result we get paralyzed by fear
and we do nothing and that's the biggest
risk of all that's when you see somebody
else making tons of money off your ideas
that's when you fast forward 10 years
and you still haven't done anything
you're still in the exact same position
that you are now meanwhile lots of
people have taken that idea that you had
and are crushing it and so the way to
get over it is to recognize that as soon
as you get an idea you need to find some
small way to test it and that you don't
have all the answers and that's okay and
that you're going to figure it out along
the way
don't be
naive like I was to think that you can
create a business plan and it's going to
be the perfect business plan you're
going to have all the answers figured
out and then you're just going to
execute that business plan because as
soon as you finish writing your business
plan and you get out into the world and
you start testing your assumptions
you'll find out that you made a lot of
mistakes that a lot of what you thought
would happen didn't happen you couldn't
predict the future you couldn't predict
how customers would react you can't come
up with the perfect plan just sitting in
your apartment sitting on your couch
going to the library you have to
actually get out and start talking to
customers test your assumptions that was
my biggest problem in my first business
I spent three months working on the
perfect business plan and then when I
got out to Market I realized a lot of
what I thought was going to happen a lot
of what I thought with the reactions
would be is now it actually happened
and that set me behind
and so being attached to that perfect
idea understand that that doesn't exist
there is no perfect plan there is no
perfect idea as soon as you get
something in your head as soon as you
get an idea for something to do
then find some small way to get out and
start testing it
find some small way to get out and start
seeing are you getting yeses are you
getting traction do you even enjoy this
a lot of times these big goals that we
have for ourselves when you get into it
you want to be a YouTuber great you
start making videos you're like yeah I
don't really like that go figure that
out as soon as possible people wait
years before they go out and try their
first attempt at it and then they
realize you know what that wasn't for me
and so I strongly encourage you to one
as soon as you get an idea for something
something you want to test out something
that you think might work find some
immediate way to test it on a small
scale don't take a big risk don't go
mortgage your house don't go take out a
giant loan I hate spending money till
I'm making money find some small way to
get started what's the most important
part of my morning routine it's
remembering the intention how do I want
today to go not just having a list of
to-do's but actually writing down how
you want to feel and that message to
yourself they'll give you the extra push
that you need to move it forward come up
with your intentions
whether you want to do my method and the
night before write down your calendar
and how you want to feel or if it's just
the first thing in the morning you're
you're looking at your calendar that's
what I used to do before writing it down
I just pull up my phone
load my calendar and just see what was
on my list for today because I'd often
forget what am I doing today I don't
know I just woke up I'm tired I look at
my calendar and then with each one I
would just mentally go through instead
of writing it how do I want to show up
for this person if I'm making YouTube
videos how do I want to show up on
camera how do I want to show up for my
audience how do I want to show up for
you I would just mentally think about
that as I go through the day and I
basically wake up go to the bathroom
pull up my phone and start going through
my calendar
that's it and how I want to feel that
the intention going through each
individual item on my calendar what I
love about this
is I find that I'm a little more
courageous at night compared to in the
morning I just had a day hopefully it
was a good day hopefully I served I
helped it's often after I answer some
questions on Instagram so I'm in the
service heart and mindset and I think
about how do I want to show up tomorrow
if you find that you have more energy at
night or more clarity or more boldness
at night then then do that think about
how do you want to show up tomorrow what
are your tasks write them down and with
each one just write down what the
intention is how do you want to show up
as a human for each one so not just a
list of to-do's but how you want to feel
going into each one
look is there even as an example every
day at 2 30 I spend time with Nina
okay
every day 2 30. take a break from
whatever I'm doing spend time with
Nathan we usually go outside for the
walk with the dogs uh if it's raining
we'll stay inside and do something
together just a quick break in the
middle of the day to spend time together
and that's in my calendar and on my
calendar it says 2 30
half an hour break with Nina
but I wrote down what's my intention
right so not just time with Nina I wrote
down
have fun and make her feel loved
and I wrote something else down
yesterday but that's my that's my
intention for today have fun and make
her feel loved so last night I wrote
that down I'm looking at Nina she's
lying in bed she's you know about to
fall asleep I don't think how do I want
to show up for her tomorrow for our
break
have fun
and make her feel loved
so I look at that again this morning
and I look at it again right now
and then here's what's gonna happen at 2
30. 2 30 I'm gonna be done filming my
videos I'm gonna look at my calendar
look at my sheet here let's say 2 30
time with Nina have fun make her feel
loved just that reminder
will make me show up differently
if your goal is to have fun if your goal
is to make somebody feel loved you're
going to show up slightly differently
I'm gonna show up with more love with
more energy maybe pull in some kind of
joke maybe picking her up and turning
her in a circle something I'm going to
show up slightly different because I
reminded myself that it's not just
a break
the intention is to have fun
and make her feel loved and so if you do
that for all of the items on your
calendar
for every meeting that you've got for
every quiet time that you've got every
creative moment that you've got how do
you want to show up if you can write it
down I love the night before and then
under each one how do you want to show
up that Prime
when you look at it just before you go
into the task will help you show up as
you'd like as your most bold courageous
proud self I think entrepreneurs are
going to solve every problem I think
whatever problem there is in the world
entrepreneurs are going to be the ones
to solve it and there's definitely a
place for government and everything else
but I just defaulted thinking it's us
it's entrepreneurs we're going to do it
we see a problem we want to fix it be
the change you want to see in the world
and and that's really at the Crux of a
successful business when people ask me
how do you make money as an entrepreneur
well you solve a problem with something
that you love doing if you are solving
somebody else's problem that they're
struggling with you can get paid to do
it and if you love doing that thing then
that's how you start having a business
right that can have success long term
sustainable if you solve a problem but
you don't love doing it you're gonna end
up burning out phasing out people will
be better than you at it it won't be
sustainable because you don't love the
thing and if you just love the thing but
you're not solving a problem then you've
got a hobby right if you love doing
something but it doesn't solve anybody's
problem you've got a hobby and it could
be fulfilling and reaching for the soul
but that's not a business it's in that
combination of what solves a real
problem that you enjoy doing that's how
you start to make money I think one of
the biggest problems though for
entrepreneurs is we don't know what the
problem is we think we know what the
problem is but we don't know what the
problem is especially when it's for
ourselves we think that we know what our
problems are but we don't actually know
our problems because we're too in the
thing have you ever notice how it's
easier to point out somebody else's
problems like you should be doing this
you know the problem with this business
they should be doing that but it's
harder to look at ourselves and say
Here's the biggest problem that I'm
facing right now at least I find this as
a challenge I'm sitting here at genius
Network this is a it's a what is it's a
mastermind it's a success circle
of people who are
having seven eight nine figure
businesses and they meet once a month to
help each other out and one of my
favorite exercises is when you
basically go down and it's called hot
seat and you think about what your
biggest problem is and they put you in
groups and then you're explaining your
problem to the other people in your
group and you get suggestions you get
feedback and these are all you know
peers people who've done equally or
maybe even more things than you have and
it's great to get at least I think a
fresh perspective and so
yesterday one of the members that I was
in that group with
he came up and he said I my biggest
problem is I need to have more structure
in my life I need to be more intentional
with my time I'm too all over the place
I'm I'm too you know creative and and
and I you know it's got me this far but
it's not going to be the thing that gets
me to the next step I need to have more
discipline and schedule
and the first uh person started giving
him some advice and and she was telling
him how she sets her schedule and give
him some feedback and
the thing that just kept throwing
flowing through my mind and when it came
to me to give advice I just asked the
question do you even want this
you know like do you even want this
and
he's like
it feels it sounds like prison
as a guy that you've been in prison
before so he knows what that feels like
he's like when I when I think about it
when I talk about it feels like I'm in
prison and that is
a classic case for a lot of
entrepreneurs who want freedom who are
creative who want to be out
like creativity is messy
creativity is messy and so you can't be
productive and you can't be efficient if
you're being creative and knowing a
little bit about him said dude that
that's not your problem see this is
where we got cut up in our own in our
own traps and our own thinking because
we can't self-diagnose very well we
often need people to help us so when he
says
my problem is I'm not being intentional
enough with my time and I'm wasting a
lot of time I need to be more structured
that's not his problem
in fact what he needs to do is the exact
opposite he needs to be spending more
time in his zone of Genius he needs to
be spending more time being creative he
needs to have the freedom to be able to
spend three days swimming with alpacas
if that's the thing that is in his mind
because it's going to lead to some
awesome new creation that if you take a
creative genius like he is and you force
him into a structure and a schedule then
he's going to end up
in a prison like he said and and just
imagine you know if he lives a week like
that versus a month like that versus six
months like that versus a year like that
the more he's trapped in that prison the
less effective he's actually going to be
he might be really efficient and
productive
for a short amount of time but he's
gonna end up hating his life and he's
not going to birth any new creative
things into the world and he's out of
his own of Genius
and so his real problem is he doesn't
have the person on his team to be that
number two to take things over
and he hasn't assigned that person the
responsibilities or given them
permission to be able to to run with
those things he's already built the
seven figure business so it's not like
I'm I'm talking to somebody who's brand
new startup doesn't know what he's doing
right this is a already successful
entrepreneur but again it's easy to spot
the problems in other people's
businesses and other people's lives and
sometimes in our own and so the problem
was different than the problem that he
thought he had
and solving the right Problem by getting
some perspective
will change his life just as I was
talking and expressing
what I thought about him you could see
these shirts that come alive and at the
end he's like I feel that this is the
guy who's really in tune with with body
and energy and is like I feel that he's
like touching his heart you know as he's
doing it and like thank you and what a
gift and so
we solved the right problem
and so
if you are struggling right now
I think one of the best things you can
do is is one model success so go find
the people who've done what you're
trying to do and see what resonates you
know Bill Gates saved my business even
though I've never met him because I had
a software company and I looked at Bill
Gates who started a software company and
that's what I modeled and it started to
work
but I think even more importantly
if you're really struggling right now is
to be around other people who might be
able to help
because you're around some people even
if you're a shy and introverted like me
you sell people some people around you
the problem is they can't tell you what
the problem is you know their their
version of the problem is something you
don't want to hear I don't believe in
negative or toxic people I don't think
that's what's going on but they're
you know hurt people hurt people so they
could be in a lot of pain they could be
hurt they have a different perspective
one that you you don't want their life
you don't respect their opinion on the
thing that you're asking about and so
you just probably around the wrong
people
and to be able to change that to shift
that to you might be able to I mean this
group here one group was 25 000 a year
being the other is a hundred thousand
dollars to be in so
um you may not be able to afford to to
go to a group like that but you don't
need it because the most you don't need
it yet you know the most important thing
is momentum to start building to start
being around more positive optimistic
happy people who you do respect you can
do something with I made a group called
movement makers and every two weeks we
meet and these are people who want to be
thought leaders who want to share want
to help have a message on their heart
and need to get out to the world and
it's great to be around me and I teach
and I share and I give my perspective
but the biggest learning I think
honestly is by them being connected to
each other by them doing challenges and
projects together by them interviewing
each other on their channels so that
they're not alone and they have people
to talk to and connect with and feel
like
like this matters and there's some
momentum because whatever you want to do
the people around you don't understand
it right if you're an entrepreneur
you're a little bit crazy it's awesome
like high five I love you celebrate but
you're a little bit crazy and different
and the people around you don't
understand you and some people might
just be supportive just not know what to
tell you and other people might be
straight out negative and say stop doing
that be practical be realistic go get a
job go to school go X go live a safe
life and you don't want that life
and so you need to start being around
the people collect good people who
support you who cheer you on who believe
in you who say that you can do things
who still push you but in a positive
left and Way Forward as opposed to a
negative way down that makes you feel
like things are possible and so how do
you find those people well
you could join a group right I mean
genius Network might be a fit for you if
you've got a big budget movement makers
might be a fit for you if you're trying
to be a thought leader but but actively
look for people actively look for events
and conferences and groups even if it's
a free meetup group at the beginning
like actively look to be around
people who are close to you or online
groups that you can join but that are
around the same interests of you because
when you're around the people who are
trying to do the same thing that you're
trying to do even if they haven't quite
done it yet it's not only mentoring
where they've done it and they're
showing you the ropes even if it's
they're trying to do it and you're
trying to do it to be around people who
are ambitious who want to chase down
their dream and goals and Achieve
something right and make something of
their lives if you're around those
people it will just fill you with more
energy
it will fill you with more energy and
make you feel like hope is possible
that'd be my immediate action item to
yes have the environment pay attention
to who you subscribe to on YouTube and
who you follow on Instagram and the
books that you're reading and the
content you're consuming does it lift
you up does it make you feel better and
belief and give you hope and strategies
and tactics on what to actually do and
look at your circle
you know you're with the right people
and if not then just don't don't don't
make it some big thing that you have to
go join this giant group that's super
expensive
just start with
who can I who can I talk to right now
you know who's trying to do this thing
with me too
who's even at my level
that I can build and grow and learn with
and if you just switch your mindset to
start to look to start the search to go
to Google and type in your city and look
for groups or to think about the
industry you want to be in like how to
be a thought leader or how to be a XYZ
whatever it is that you are in whatever
your business is and Define groups of
people who are doing it you know you
want to be a Toastmasters for speakers
or whatever it is there's a group
to just join and try it because man when
you're around people who are doing
things
it just breathes so much more Life
Energy and momentum into your mission
figure out what your trigger words are
what are your trigger words what are the
things that you say to yourself that
keep you small that keep you scared that
keep you safe that keep you from living
your dreams what are the trigger words
that you use so for me it's scary
difficult and hard whenever I say scary
difficult to hard those are the things
that have become my trigger words and
now I have to go do the things because I
said them because I wrote them I texted
them I sent them I thought them right
when you when you figure out what your
trigger words are then
whenever you say them it's an indication
of here I am again playing small here I
am again telling myself that I can't do
it here I am again accepting these
reasons that I no longer want to accept
being afraid is a classic one for a lot
of people well I didn't do it because I
was afraid and we've accepted you've
accepted the fact that you're afraid as
being a good enough reason for you not
to do the thing that you want to do
and I would like to challenge that and
say that's no longer good enough reason
nope not anymore not for you not for
what you're capable of not for where you
want to go not for the impact that you
can have nope not a good enough reason
anymore let's go
so if you just sit and think about what
are the trigger words that you say what
are the what's the language that you use
that keeps you small scared protected
that you no longer want to be good
enough reasons that you want to be free
of rid of and that we're taking from our
subconscious mind automatic patterns
into our conscience and to know I am
going to make a change in my life I no
longer want to be this person I need to
evolve and grow and get better and be
better because I'm capable right you so
when you figure out your your trigger
words and and try to cope with them it's
a good exercise to do right now what are
the words that you tell yourself
when you're scared when you're afraid
when you've got big ideas and you talk
yourself down from what are the what's
the language you use you can start by
just taking on mine scary difficult hard
or you can come up with your own but
they did become anytime you see yourself
using that language
it triggers you to then make a shift to
say oh okay because I said that because
I said scary difficult or hard now I'm
going to do it just because because I'm
the kind of person who does scary who
does difficult who loves hard
and when you can take those words that
have previously disempowered you and
flipped them so that they be they become
empowering for you that's how you start
to shift your identity forward at the
end of the day the thing that matters is
is how you feel about yourself when
you're by yourself the language you use
to talk about yourself the messaging you
have to yourself when you look at
yourself in the mirror when you're going
to sleep when there's nobody else around
you because when you can build that
self-belief when you can build that
self-love when you can build that
self-confidence that self-esteem
that becomes the rocket fuel for you to
build the great life for you your family
the people around you and create the
impact that you know you're capable of
having what is the life that you want
what are the goals that you have for
yourself where do you want to be in your
health and your relationships and your
business your finances what do you
actually want out of life not what
somebody else's perfect life looks like
right you go on Instagram and you see
people
living on the beach and and rolling
around in money like that maybe that's
what you want but maybe it's not what
you want and we get pulled into all
these different directions because we
don't have Clarity over what we actually
want so what do you actually want what
do you want out of life where do you
want your business to be what kind of
company do you want to run what are the
what are the ethics and morals that your
company is based off of who do you want
to serve and how do you want to help
them how do you want to show up in your
relationship who are you looking for in
your partner if you already have a
partner you know how do you want to show
up better for them
all of the things that matter to you to
get as clear as possible so that when
you see somebody else is doing something
else and they're happy great you don't
have to go do it because you're happy
chasing down your goals part of the
challenge is we see other people who are
happy
and often it's not even real happiness
it's just you know fake happiness for
the camera but you see somebody who
looks happy you know that you're not
happy and you think well maybe if I did
that then I'll be happy you know maybe
if I go write a poem like they did I'll
be happy and then you start to write a
poem because I hate writing poems right
so it's getting clear over what do you
actually want in your life who's the
person that you want to be
in any again from your finances to your
your business to the relationships to
your uh to health to different areas of
your life get as clear as you can on the
things that you want out of your life
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there at some point you have to decide
whose life you're living are you living
your version of your life are you living
your parents version of your life or
your friend's version of your life or
your community's version of your life or
society's version of your life so
everybody has a goal for you